two and one
you want to try again is it all going
you're good sorry about that
um we've got some new tech and I'll
explain that in a second for you
um so I'll say yeah phones if you could
please um at the very least term silence
I don't mind people using them as long
as it doesn't disturb the flow of the
meeting we're not expecting a fire alarm
if one does go off please if you would
follow us to the a car park over the
road next to the windmill Pub we will
need to make sure that we check all your
names off before you leave just make
sure you're out the building safely
before we send you on your Merry Little
way the meeting itself is a meeting in
public it is not a public meeting so
only the people that have been
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so
at the appropriate time I will call you
forward I'll give you a lot of time for
your speech and if you sit at any one of
the three desks in front of us you can
you can deliver it from there we do have
new microphones you don't need to press
any buttons to get them started
um we will as soon as you start speaking
the volume will be turned up and you'll
be heard
it's close the closer you can get to the
microphone the better because obviously
it picks it up better typically about a
hand's width should do the job um but as
I say if you sit in front of one of
these as soon as you start speaking it
will pick you up
let's get into
um some introductions if I may so to my
far right we have uh Kira Keller who is
our Community Services representative to
my immediate right we have Amy Shipley
who is our solicitor and our planners
who are sat over here in no particular
order are Louise Coleman Victoria
Kempton Stuart McIver and lanika Agnew
and to my immediate left is Emily Napier
who is our planning manager Emily could
you I believe you've got a statement to
make I do thank you chat my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice to
committee members and to assist members
in their decision taking
fabulous thank you very indeed let's get
into the meeting itself
um so first of all apologies for absence
we have an apologies please we do we
have apologies from councilor Hench
yourself marvelous thank you very much
and disclosures of Interest members I'm
going to kick us off if I may so um
first of all uh we have application
reference 2202 318 ful that's total the
green and sniff field I'm the ward
member and I have registered to speak so
I will be removing myself from the table
at which point councilor Kendall will be
taking the chair on my behalf
um on the first item we're hearing
tonight which will be application
reference
2102017 ful as land at crims cut in
Winston
um I have received three separate emails
one from the applicant one from uh
Stephen Nori of Stratford climate
um group and another one if someone's I
can't remember who it was cpre it was
um I'm going to assume that everyone
else has received the same I'm seeing a
lot of nodding so we'll do that as a
blanket one anyone else have any
disclosures they'd like to make
counselor Harvey yes um in relation to
item four the application land at Prim
Scott my position is well known because
I have submitted my comments 15 months
ago so I shall be leading the table
while that is discussed similarly uh
item six treading Hill Barnes and the
ward member I will speak I'm registered
to speak I'll leave the table for that
meeting for that item as well lovely
thank you very much councilor Rock
please
um I'm the ward member for item four
um
I think that's right item seven sorry uh
and I'll be leaving the cable disabled
to speak and will not participate in the
decision otherwise and instead thank you
and cancer Curtis thank you yes um
21021
02017 I live in Alderman so I'm a member
of alderminster Parish Council but I
wasn't a member of the parish council
when they submitted their no objection
originally
so I approach this one open mind okay
Abby thank you very much anyone else
no marvelous okay um next item is
minutes everyone happy with the minutes
is presented in the agenda pack quick
thumbs up yeah lovely I will sign those
after the meeting okay let's get into
our first I uh real item uh of the
evening which is application reference
2102017ful land at kremska in Winston
our presenting officer is Louise Coleman
Louise over to you
thank you chair
site is located approximately 660 meters
Northwest of krimskit and 2.8 kilometers
north of illmington
[Music]
the site which is demarked by with the
red line is approximately 59.4 hectares
of agricultural land made up of six
Fields the site is situated between Red
Hill Bank road and crimskirt road
the site a butts Winston Fields Farm
Complex which comprises of industrial
storage sheds and poultry buildings
together with a small cluster of
Residential Properties along part of its
Northwestern boundary dwellings known as
Lee's farm and Willow Lawn previously
known as tranquil lie to the West a
public right-of-way identified by the
green hatch line terminates close to the
western boundary of the site further
public footpaths are located to the
South and Southwest and the Monarch way
Centenary way footpath is located
approximately 2.9 kilometers to the west
of the site
there are no statutory designations on
the site however it lies approximately
2.3 kilometers east of the Cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty and
one kilometer west of felden special
landscape area
there are no listed buildings within the
site and the site lies within flood zone
one
the proposals seek to construct a solar
farm with supporting equipment including
battery storage containers a 15 meter
high telecoms Mast access tracks
inverter cabins so inverter units a
customer cabin underground cables and
grid connection substation
the application is for a temporary
40-year period with the exception of a
substation which has been applied for on
a permanent basis
the anticipated capacity of the solar
farm is 49.9 megawatts and underground
cables would connect the development to
the grid via an existing overhead line
approximately 200 meters to the east of
the site entrance
the panels themselves have a maximum
height of 3 meters and are mounted
between 0.6 and 1.2 meters on off the
ground perimeter fencing around the site
will be two meters in height
CCTV cameras would be mounted on poles
measuring 3.5 meters and telecom's mass
wouldn't have a maximum height of 15
meters and finally Associated building
structures and plant a maximum of 5.9
the arrangement of the panels is shown
on the layout plan where the substation
and telecoms mass Venus located uh close
to the industrial storage sheds and
poultry buildings at Winstone Fields
Farm
in this area here
this is an elevation of the Mast
telecoms Mast which as I say is what has
a maximum height of 15 meters
this is the Landscaping proposals
existing Hedgerow and tree planting
around the boundaries of the site are
proposed to be retained and supplemented
in areas especially along the southern
boundary in addition there would be
planting in the land edged in blue which
are booked crimskirt road with there are
patches with no planting in there that's
which would be planted up with new
hedgerows
new Woodland areas are proposed along
the southwestern Northern and
Northeastern boundaries together with
new Hydro planting new Wildflower and
grass mix areas within the site itself
and also along the northern boundary
[Music]
access is proposed to be off a new point
of Red Hill Bank Road with a new
priority Junction with visibilities uh
with a setback of 2.4 meters in forward
visibility in 215 in both directions
turning now to photographs of the site
and this is a view taken from Red Hill
Bank Road looking at Lee's farm so the
um black line identifies the extent of
the um application sorry the red the red
line identifies the area of development
in the black line identifies where the
panels approximate location of the
panels would go and all of these
photographs
this is a view just panning around
slightly so where the proposed access
points would be and then the access road
and then the start of the panels
themselves
and I'm going to show you a series of
photographs which do include photo
montages that have been provided by the
applicants so this is a view you can see
from here taken from crimskirt Downs
which is a public footpath south of the
site so this is looking at the existing
area this is photo montage showing as as
proposed
and then this is indicative
um of after 15 years with proposed
planting but obviously members need to
be bearing in mind this is indicative
and all of these views
and turning now to photo montage three
so this is looking at a view from
crimskirt road so with existing Year One
and then indicatively after 15 years
this is a view from Monarch's way and
Centenary way to the east sorry
apologies to the west of the site
looking
down at the application area
so Lee's Farm is identified here with
Winston Fields farm at the back so
that's existing and then we go into
photo montage of year one
[Music]
and then photo montage of year 15 with
indicative planting
finally this is a view from the public
right-of-way the west of Elmington again
the view here
so this is as existing
this is proposed
Year One
[Music]
and then indicatively with the planting
after 15 years
there are two updates for members to
note and the recommendation is to Grant
planning Commissioners subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed in the
report thank you chair
Louise thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is Dr David Buckley of whitchurch
Parish meeting
good evening
[Applause]
so Dr Bucky you'll have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up if you can stay seated
for questions afterwards I'll be
grateful otherwise as soon as you're sat
comfortable and ready to go the floor is
yours okay
okay
speaking on behalf of Richard's Parish I
should like to emphasize that we are
supportive of green energy I myself have
installed solar panels a battery storage
system and drive a full electric car but
we are also aware of the downsides and
although this application is a good idea
it is in the wrong place and the
benefits do not outweigh the harm done
our crisis presently is twofold energy
security and food security this plan
trades one for the other when this
choice is not necessary there are
suitable Alternatives core strategy
policy CS3 on sustainable energy and in
particular solar energy states the need
to one consider the impact on
agricultural activities the farm
currently produces important arable
crops of Wheat and oil rape seed two the
need to consider the impact on the
openness and character of the landscape
and on the visual immunity focusing on
this the Warwickshire landscape
guidelines state that the Landscapes
within the feldom vale farmlands are of
medium to high sensitivity to solar
developments over 25 hectares this site
is significantly larger at 59.5 hectares
the planning officer acknowledges that
the proposed development would introduce
a substantial new character change and
the landscape officer also considered
that this is likely to have a
significant effect on the landscape
character in particular the open
boundary referred to in the report along
the c-141 Crimson road which has open
views across the land is intensively
used for recreation by Walkers cyclists
Runners and horse riders and the site
Amper impact will be severely
detrimental to the character and
appearance of this area contrary to
policy cs1 CS5 of the adopted core
strategy and as-10 of the draft core
strategy this site the size of 111
football pitches with panels up to three
meters high surrounded by 2.5 meter
security fencing 3.5 meter poles with
cameras on top this will look like an
mod site the applicant promises
mitigation which sits outside of the
plan we were promised similar planting
at other sites and these have failed to
be delivered and the planning office are
unlikely to enforce this due to lack of
Manpower and expense I therefore urge
the committee to visit the sites and
also to Wilmington Hill an area of
outstanding natural beauty to see the
visual impact and potential glint and
glare created as it lies directly south
of the development and as such is likes
to be far more impactful than that at
Blackwell in addition to being six times
larger 30 seconds if you do decide to
Grant this application I urge you to
seek section 106 expenses for the repair
of the road from c48 in whimstone to c71
in darling's coat these roads were
inevitable inevitably suffer
considerable damage as was the case when
Clifford Chambers was closed for only
four weeks as this development entailed
six months of an additional 22 500 hgv
Journeys the damage for which the
taxpayer will otherwise be responsible
for thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr sparkly thank you very much spot on
three minutes thank you for that members
have any questions councilor Parry first
please
good evening Dr Buckley I just I just
wonder
ing
um I just wondering whether you can
advise uh this committee the extent of
the consultation
from the applicant and how the applicant
has engaged with the local community
I haven't seen them once
and I don't think they put they put on a
meeting but I think that a lot of it was
uh
uh a waste of time it was we'll promise
you this we'll promise you that there's
no promises of anything and what worries
us about the the commitments that they
say that they've put in this because
nobody's going to enforce them so
there's they've given no indication of
anything there is no Community there's
no benefit to the community at all
Council Mills next please
Council Perry has was the same question
no problem Council Crump please
you meant you mentioned Trading food
security for energy security I've tried
to look through the report but I
couldn't see what was actually on the
land that's been farmed at the moment
could you tell me what it is please well
it's been graded um as 3B but I expect
that there are areas that are clearly 3A
of high quality because they have grown
rapeseed oil in the past and we've seen
that it's grown wheat and various crops
I don't know what they're growing on it
at the moment because it's all Barren
they also do have sheep on there on
occasions so there's a mixture of
farming going on on it
um they certainly have going crops and
as we've seen this is very important
because we import 80 percent of our food
and this is disgraceful because that
what it's all very well for us all to
um think that we're doing the right
thing but this is contributing to CO2
and it's going to rise if we get rid of
Arabic we're somewhat straying away from
the question there I'll let you go a
little bit let's just make sure we stick
to the questions we've got a lot to get
through so they do they do um it's an
arable
but what they've grown this year I don't
know we'll perhaps ask that of the agent
the applicant later on yeah thank you
councilor Curtis next please thank you
um doctor you mentioned some I believe
some other sites in reference to
mitigation planting that hadn't taken
place now
um can you just clarify are these by the
same developer no thank you
any other questions members
no Dr sparkly thank you very much your
time contribution this evening thank you
foreign
[Applause]
our next speaker of the evening who is
Mr Richard gotch from Crim's cut
community on behalf of crimskirt
community I should say
[Applause]
good evening sir thank you very much for
your patience um once again you will
have three minutes I will give you a 30
second warning before your time is up
but otherwise whenever you're sat comes
from ready to go the floor is yours
thank you very much
president of the national Farmers Union
recently stated that the UK has no food
security strategy at the time food was
relatively cheap as a result of 80
percent being imported but challenges
with Supply mean that food is no longer
cheap North Cotswold Food Bank says the
number of emergency Parcels handed out
from April to September has more than
doubled importing 80 percent of our food
also has a severe impact on our
environment 26 percent is brought To Us
by hundreds of diesel trucks every day
the majority of the rest reaches Us by
ship a murder transport that is one of
the world's worst polluters this is not
a small solar farm with minimum impact
at 147 Acres it is more than twice the
maximum size recommended in the
Warwickshire landscape guidelines
that also makes it very hard to hide the
landscape officer has stated that it
will have a significant effect on
landscape character as one local
resident told me from a popular Beauty
Spot in the Cotswold Hills you can see
this site and two other solar sites
without moving your head
I mentioned this to show that citing a
new solar power station is a complex
decision we are asking you to understand
that responding to the climate emergency
does not excuse us from the
responsibility to consider the wider
implications of our decisions
with this in mind the government's draft
policy statement for renewable energy
infrastructure states that where
possible ground-mounted solar projects
should avoid the use of agricultural
land classified as best and most
versatile
the exclusion of grade 3B land from this
classification is very much Up For
Debate in June this year the defra
Secretary of State emphasized that it
does include 3B and above however
responding to pressure from Lobby groups
he backed down but it shows how marginal
this division is it's particularly
marginal at this site where the land
quality grades from 3A to 3B
just last week the new government
concerned that much needed work on
revising the current guidance continues
our country needs a joined up strategy
that improves food security while
ensuring food is Affordable which
protects our Countryside as a treasured
immunity for us and for our children and
which also enables the undoubted
benefits of solar energy
but these vast solar power stations must
be in responsible locations such as
Factory roofs car park canopies an
integral with new housing developments
as they are in many other countries 30
seconds the transition from
short-sighted profit-driven development
desola as a joined up strategy doesn't
have to start with national government
it can start here with local government
by deciding on a planned green future
instead of the ad hoc profit driven
future that is being presented today
thank you
all right
[Applause]
Minister gotch thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our speaker please councilor Dixon
first of all she mentioned I think that
from a certain Beauty Spot Viewpoint
various solar Farms could already be
seen can you tell me where that
Viewpoint was please yes this is the
bench on Foster Hill Fox got Hill thank
you okay any other questions for our
speaker
no in that case Mr watch thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening thank you very much
[Applause]
okay we'll call forward our final
speakers on this application and we have
three of them so um we have sherry
Gregory the agent we have Stephen calper
and we have John stopped
if you would like to make your way
forward
sorry say that again John style is
dropped out okay so we have a Stephen
Capital with us
are you speaking I've got your
registered to speak so if you want to
come forward to set up one of the
I've got you registered in the same slot
would you would you mind coming forward
I've got your reverse registered in this
lot so between you you've got six
minutes how are you going to split your
time three minutes okay three years so
what we'll do is for three minutes three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning for your three minutes up when
three minutes is there I'll let you know
you can start and then we'll do
questions for both of you afterwards if
that's all right okay so um whenever
you're ready good evening chair and
members of the planning committee
in terms of the openness and character
of the landscape and visual amenity the
site is not located within or adjacent
to a nationally or locally designated
landscape
the site is dominated by the industrial
style style sheds south of williamstone
fields Farm
as shown in our studies and in agreement
with the council's landscape officers
the visual impact was not found to be
significant from surrounding public
views
the photo montage is submitted with the
application demonstrate the limited
visibility of the site from various
locations and took account of the
existing solar farms in the assessment
they found that no single location
affords a view of more than one solar
farm
nevertheless so I'm gonna put
ladies and gentlemen
all of our all the speakers that we've
had so far have um been allowed to speak
without interruption I'd be very
grateful if you would not moan groan
shout or make a noise while our speakers
are speaking I understand you have a
view you've had your opportunity to make
that view known please because we need
to listen to what people have to say
sorry about that I have stopped your
time I will give you a couple of seconds
to get going again and I'll start again
nevertheless we've included proposals
for boundary hedgerows a 30 meter wide
Woodland belt and a new Orchard
alongside 52 hectares of Wildflower
planting and 4.75 hectares for Farmland
Birds these measures would deliver
significant biodiversity gain of greater
than 50 percent
the 40-year life of the solar farm will
allow the soil to rest during which time
it accumulates organic matter rather
than lose it through Crop Production
should the solar farm be built it will
still serve an agricultural function
through grazing sheep
research from Tara farmer a consultancy
specializing in advising UK farms and
sustainable farming states that
traditional solar Farms with Steve
grazing work to suppress their carbon
and help rebuild soil health
in terms of Transport on the average day
during construction there would be only
nine hdv movements in contract to what
the cancer is stating
when compared to the average daily
traffic flow on the a3400 the traffic
generated from the construction of the
solar farm reflects less than a one
percent increase
the peak month of hgv movements would
see 25 hdb movements per day which is
just short of an 18 increase I'll allow
while noticeable it's compared with the
blow Baseline flow level of only 142
movements and it's for a temporary
period
the Warwickshire County Highway does not
object to the proposal subject to our
compliance with conditions
Yorkshire County highways does not
object to the proposal subject to our
compliance with conditions
in terms of community benefit we've
entered into an agreement with works for
wildlife trust to fund Grassroots
environmental projects to benefit
residents a Stratford upon even District
Council the trust will receive just
under 15 000 pounds per year every year
over the course of the life of the solar
farm for a total of six hundred thousand
pounds
the trust will seek Community input to
determine how spent the funds are spent
locally 30 seconds separately
discussions have been ongoing since
April 2021 for a community Energy Group
to acquire the project once constructed
the benefit of community ownership is
that profits of the scheme can only be
can be recycled into localized benefits
through a Community Fund our preference
has always been for the site to be
acquired by a local community Energy
Group
in line of the officer's recommendation
to approve and no objections from
statutory consulties I respectfully
request you approve this application
marvelous thank you very much that was
just inside your three minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
the good news for you miss cappers you
get an extra three seconds you use it as
wisely whenever you're ready I will
start the timer the floor's yours
we were first approached in 2014 about
the possibility of constructing a solar
Park on some of our land at this point
we were looking at it purely commercial
view but unfortunately the company we
were dealing with at the time failed to
get a grid connection so this was taken
no further when we were approached Again
by regenerate eight years later our view
had changed somewhat uh we were now
struggling to control black grass which
is a very invasive weed due to lack of
new chemistry and increasing resistance
to existing chemicals due to the nature
of our heavy clay soils we are unable to
reliably grow spring crops on our land
so this is neither the reliable nor
economic method of control of this weed
this however was not the main reason for
considering again we now had a
government that was no longer supporting
agricultural production but instead had
its focus on environmental schemes but
most importantly for us we now had
grandchildren and will become an
increasingly concerned about the future
they face with global warming
we've watched many programs about the
risk we're all facing in the future but
what really brought this home was
visiting the Rome Glacier in Switzerland
earlier this year and seen photographic
evidence of exactly how far this classes
retreated in the last 20 years
we all know we need to address this
situation to counter the issues we all
face and whilst we could all return to
living very simple lives burning less
fossil fuel this is unlikely to happen
so we need to find ways to generate as
much genuinely renewable energy as
possible
the argument for food production on our
land or any other land is a valuable
point however we must bear in mind uh we
currently grow wheat which goes to
service star in Manchester which is then
turned into ethanol which will find its
way back into your cars and the Aussie
rate which we grow is a high heuristic
variety which again is crushed but it's
for use in Plastics and personal care
products
we must also bear in mind all the other
uses of agricultural land that currently
take place such as growing feedstocks
for anaerobic digestion Vineyards which
become an increasingly common golf
courses forestry and of course the many
thousands of Acres which currently stand
at close to 900 000 Acres up from three
hundred thousand acres just eight years
ago which are in environmental schemes
which produce very little
the establishment of a solar Park on
this piece of land which is relatively
isolated will produce a sound and
reliable income which will enable us to
continue farming the roaming land and
provide a secure future for our children
and grandchildren and when I say our I
mean all of our not just mine
as I'm sure you're aware there is a
finite amount of energy available from
the Sun where you can capture this as
plant growth animal growth wind solar
power many forms we have the problem
there are limited areas to produce all
our own needs so we will always have to
import
I personally would rather import grain
from Canada than gas from Russia
[Applause]
thank you to both members do we have any
questions for our speakers please
councilor Crump first
sir sir
um
I asked the question to um
to Dr Buckley about what the line is
currently for and you I heard you
mention it was
um rapeseed oil um
and obviously you explain where it's
going what type of quality land is it is
it 3a3b it's 3B 3B thank you
um are my rides can I just have a
slightly a moment
um and are you saying this is helping
the viability of the farm by having this
absolutely
we're we're facing I don't know how much
time we're allowed to pass it we're
facing
huge problems at the moment as everybody
is with increasing inputs the value the
cost to us to produce wheat I have to be
fair or I put my hand in the air and say
we had a very good year last year
because we bought in at low prices and
sold as we went up at high prices it's a
completely different story now wheat is
going down the price of fuel has risen
dramatically the price of fertilizers to
a minute risen dramatically in the price
of your agrochemicals is missing
dramatically
I'd be very surprised in 10 years time
at current prices if anyone's actually
producing wheat in this country
one more and you mentioned something
about an invasive week sorry you
mentioned something about an invasive
weed uh black grass yes very invasive
weed uh it's been been a problem on
heavy ground like ours for lots of years
but in the last 10 it has become a major
problem it is the number one problem in
the UK there are virtually no chemicals
which will control it successfully once
it's more than that high and we stack
lots of chemicals on the ground to try
and control it sometimes effective
sometimes not to the extent where some
years we just burn the crop off
because that's the only way to control
it
thank you councilor Parry next please
good evening Mr Cowper
um I wonder whether you can advise
um where the nearest residential
dwelling is that is not
connected to either your ownership or
your family ownership from the solar
farm I was just trying to are we talking
about a residential dwelling that can
actually sit I wasn't joking that was
actually a voiced an opinion
how far away is the nearest restaurant
dwelling that is not not related to me
but that is not related to you or your
family there are some Cottages
associated with the uh in sort of on the
bottom left hand side of your screen
where all the ultra units and other
other industrial units are there are
some houses there
The Cottages Farm Workers Cottages there
and
can I just ask another
um when I asked Dr Buckley
um about your consultation or engagement
with a local Parish Council he seemed to
infer that that there wasn't any or
certainly very much but my understanding
is that they have tried very hard
yeah so
thank you
yeah so to address your question
counselor contact was made with the
parish and board counselors to invite
them to the webinar that we held as part
of our Outreach uh there was very little
response to that unfortunately and we
could have carried forward that
conversation if there were
okay councilor Curtis next please
thank you um
first of all just pick you up on your
last comment um the webinar were there
any attempts to have live meetings made
in local Village Halls to actually meet
residents at the time covered
guidance in place prevented us from
doing so you'll understand this
application went in June 2021 and so our
community outreach was done before that
in the lead up to the submission of the
application
[Music]
thank you I've just just got three other
quick questions if I may
um you heard obviously there's a bit of
an outcry from from the gallery when you
mentioned that the other solar Farms
couldn't be seen
do you know the bench on Fox to the hill
and the view from the bench on Fox good
Hill
I can describe the viewpoints that we
need so I'm just asking if you know
thank you
um
you mentioned I think people you gave a
lot of very helpful information you
mentioned I think a one percent increase
of hgvs on the a3400 what was what was
the percentage of increase on hgvs on
the smaller roads through crimskirt for
example over the crimska bridge which is
quite important
we had to focus on traffic movement on
the a3400 because that's where it's
being measured to be fair so I don't
have that data it's not publicly
available or being measured
so you you don't have data for hdv
increases on the very minor rural rate
no I do not know and just one more
positive I hope
um you mentioned something about the
community energy schemes or groups could
you just give a little more information
on that please
so
we're we we tend to bring projects
through the planning process and we have
a variety of options once we've gone
through that we can sell that on to uh
to be actually built uh in this case
we've been in conversation with a group
I don't want to mention them given that
we don't have an agreement in place but
they are workshop-based who would take
on ownership of the project and share
the community and start share their
profits with the community
Council Kendall next please
it's okay I'm just trying to get an idea
of what sort of things you farm
currently is it just wheat and rapeseed
oil at the moment on the rest of your
land including this particle
um on all of my I've got wheat aborted
rape one of the fields in question which
is one that's destined for the solar
part or not uh it's currently uh fallow
because there is so much black rice on
there I cannot grow a crop on it this
year and then a couple of my other
fields are in Grass okay mainly for my
daughter's Livery okay my follow-up
question was really because it was
mentioned during the presentation that
it would be possible to graze sheep
underneath the um solar panels are you
planning to switch into livestock and
sheep sheep farming or not I can't see
any issue with Grace and sheep under
there at all are you planning to switch
to that
as far as I'm aware if we're allowed to
gray sheep under it we will be growing
sheep under because it's it's the
simplest and easiest way to control the
grass yeah thank you tidy that's all I
wanted thank you cancer Mills thanks
please you've been you've saved
president David yes okay any other
speakers or questions I should say sorry
no in that case to you both thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
[Applause]
and our final speaker on this item is
councilor fitter good evening councilor
fitter
foreign
I think you know the drill you'll have
five minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up whenever
you're ready settled seated and good to
go the floor is yours great good evening
thank you Mr chairman so um this
application isn't a debate on climate
change and solar panels uh tonight we
are assessing this application against
our core policies and I'm here to object
so firstly I'm really disappointed in
the application and the consultation
residents promise local benefits but all
we have are negatives Road chaos a
destruction to the landscape and a loss
of 111 football pitches worth of
agricultural land so for anyone watching
the World Cup you'll be able to
understand how substantial are they that
this is
so an area of concern for me is the
location of this massive solar farm
situated on a very narrow NDC Road
the construction of the solar farm is
going to cause chaos for local residents
and Road users
I don't think it's right for one of the
biggest solar farms uh to be going here
our district and even my ward has a
wealth of suitable sites and I think
this is possibly one of the worst
a local resident has provided me some
further information that I wanted to
share about the entrance visibility
display for this development
so the visibility display was shown on
page 19 of the officer's report is 215
meters in each direction from the
proposed entrance from a point 2.4
meters from the edge of the high of the
highway
the neighboring property which seems to
have been ignored as a boundary hedge
that runs for 130 meters just next to
the proposed entrance
so the visibility Supply requirements
from highways cannot be met and I would
advise against highways altering someone
else's private property without their
permission and I'm pretty certain that
they don't and want and won't have it
so another reason why the location is
wrong is um this development
is going to be visible from me on Hill
which is one of the greatest and
historic Landscapes I think in
Warwickshire if not England
um and it's also enjoyed by the public
there's also visual impacts from the
Elmington Hills which are in the aonb
and also visible from Scott Hill it is
also within a mile of another solar farm
so there's quite a substantial amount of
landscape damage going on here and I
think that this proposal goes massively
against CS5
um we've spoken a bit about agricultural
lands today
um and again with lot we're losing 147
Acres of viable unproductive land here
and this goes against CS3 so I think
that this application
um is in the wrong place and of the
wrong size thank you
[Applause]
Council officer thank you very much well
within your five minutes
um members we have any questions for our
world member councilor Curtis first of
all
thanks Chad thank you councilor Visa
um
you you mentioned that there are other
sites in your ward other more suitable
sites and without asking you to go into
any detail of those at all
um would they would they be a give a
comparative sort of size to this yeah
yeah do you think they would be a proper
Alternatives yeah thank you
just for my members we are obviously
making the decision based on what's in
front of us not what is elsewhere or
could be elsewhere
um any other questions for our war
member
Council Mills
um councilor fitter um you say it can be
seen from iomb
yes it can be I think so yeah
uh has that been established
no it hasn't been established I believe
you can see it from from the Owings and
hills and and also Mill Hill it can be
okay thank you in my opinion
okay any other questions for councilor
fitter no in that case counts fitter
thank you very much your time
contribution this evening
foreign
clarification of our officers members do
we have anything we would like
clarifying from our officers please
councilor Parry first of all please
um thank you
um a couple of things
on the visibility displays
um councilor fitter highlighted that the
Hedgerow identified by Warwickshire
highways would need to be removed
obviously if that Hedgerow is in the
ownership of another landowner
um
then that visibility splay could not be
undertaken
um as far as the conditions are
concerned if we were
um minded to Grant
um
would it be possible to ensure that that
visibility splay with obviously with
construction traffic coming in
um be completed prior to the
commencement of construction
and certainly the access has to be
carried out in accordance with the
approved drawings
um the approved drawings identifies
flavor of 250 meters in either direction
the highway Authority have been out and
assessed the access position
um they are aware of the existing
Hedgerow treatments
um and they have clarified that if an
existing Hedgerow were to be encroaching
on Highway land that there is a you are
able in order to trim back a Hedgerow
that's not in your ownership both is in
over overgrowing onto Highway land then
yes it can be trimmed back but it's and
from their opinion its um displays could
be achieved hence there
um no objection
regarding uh the application with regard
to the public right-of-way deviation
um again with that
um obviously there is
it's an unknown quantity because we're
waiting for
um the footpath people to come back
again is it
um would it be reasonable if we reminded
to Grant to ask for construction to wait
for that confirmation from the footpath
[Applause]
because obviously what we've got in
front of us I know that there's a
proposal that say that they would allow
some space if if the footpath had to be
moved but we're trying to judge this
application in terms of what is in front
of us and I would just like some
guidance whether
the it's possible to await for the
decision on the
um whatever it is called the dmmo yeah
some guidance on it please thank you the
dmmo was submitted in 2005.
it's still in process there is no
indication when that will be determined
and at the end of that process there's
an appeal procedure which could be
entertained so to withhold a consent on
this application on the outcome of that
process
um
bearing in mind that the applicant has
advised that in the event of
um the diversional well sorry the
modification order being except agreed
um they would put forward an amendment
to the scheme if it was in or already be
under construction
they would amend that so they could then
accommodate for that amended footpath
route or they can apply for a footpath
diversion order
of a retrospective perspective thank you
okay councilor Rock next thank you
chairman a couple of points uh relating
to um things that have been raised this
evening uh so we've got a proposed
condition 10. uh details of lighting I
think objectives have been saying it
will look like a
logistics yard or something I presumably
when if if it was approved those
conditions would address light pollution
and so forth so that would be considered
by officers certainly thank you uh the
second Point relates to community
contributions that were mentioned uh
should the site be sold on and the agent
has said their agents that they're only
acting as agents and there would be
somebody else come along and operate it
I take it that's not something we have
we can't require a section 106 or
something like that that something can
be put forward that's not not in our
control and would not be relevant to the
application that's that's correct thank
you thank you chairman no problem at all
councilman Mills next please
um
Louise I couldn't quite understand where
Mr account was talking about the um
actually didn't get a distance between
between the
closest residential buildings but what
is the distance between
this site and the closest
residential the there are Residential
Properties
um my cursor doesn't seem to follow what
you see uh uh what's sorry I just want
to know what the distance is
I haven't got a distance
immediately to have
the the site is is here the solar panels
are proposed here
um
so it is in close proximity to The
Cottages that they're the closest ones
and that there is another property
um known as
um
apologies it says it's tranquil there
but it's not actually known as that
anymore Willow Lawn thank you
um so those are the closest properties
to the side and right we don't know just
okay
thank you okay
any other questions or points for
clarification Council Curtis please
thank you
um just one point of clarification
really it's about the the measurement
and the number of homes that I I believe
I raised this before and Page 20
um says the export capacity of the solar
file was being calculated to provide
enough electricity to power around 14
100 homes
and in the next paragraph it says this
would be consumed locally
but the data from the business energy
and Industrial strategy for Stratford
District gives quite different figures
and on that basis
it would be around ten and a half
thousand homes now that may not
necessarily be material to whether this
panel this committee
approved or not but I think if we are
being told that this energy will be
consumed locally then we should be
looking at the figures for consumption
within Stratford District which are not
the same as for the UK as a whole
we have asked that question in
anticipation
and the figures for Stratford District
aren't available but they are for the
region of the West Midlands region are
different from the national figure which
is the national figure which has been
provided in the report is the Fourteen
thousand
um apologies I haven't got that where
are we 14 100 but for the West Midlands
region it goes down to 13 400 homes and
that's was requested from the agent
it's just that the from the excellent
um presentation the council's had on
Renewal Energy
um we got here in front of me that data
from the bis
b-e-i-s and consumption per meter for
domestic but I think this is perhaps
that let's leave that for now but I
think we do need accurate or should have
accurate data that relates to the
district rather than more generally
might just have a couple other quick
clarifications who I may share
um page 32 of the report
um
it says that there could be long-term
employment associated with the
maintenance of the equipment and that
could be a benefit
but
do you have an estimate of how much
long-term employment would be generated
and would that outweigh the loss of any
traditional agricultural employment on
this land
[Music]
I would say that's that we don't have
any specific numbers of in terms of
employees that are going to be coming
forward on the on the site in terms of
day-to-day maintenance however it's it's
an it's a matter that members need to
weigh up in terms of the planning
balance
if we're being asked to weigh it up
we're not actually being given any data
on how many new jobs would be created or
how many may be lost
there's no evidence to support that
statement actually
[Music]
um so what just to go back what page was
that this is Page 32.
sorry
[Music]
there is a benefit from the scheme of
long-term employment and I'm just asking
really how much long-term employment
would be created and would that offset
any loss of employment in traditional
agriculture on the same land
it could be a zero guiding
times
[Music]
yeah no I'm happy for you to say that
um
I think yeah as councilor Richards has
said ultimately
um it
there is the potential there for some
form of employment but we don't have the
exact figures to hand so I wouldn't want
to attribute too much right
um finally can I just I'll show you
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen this is a
whilst this is a meeting in public it's
not public meeting I'm hearing a lot of
chatter from the crowd I don't
understand your emotion about this
people have a view Etc and you're here
to voice that we do need to be able to
hear our officers so that we can make an
informed decision so if you could please
refrain from chattering and shouting I'd
be very grateful Council Curtis sorry
thank you final point I'll be very good
um if the development is sold on on
completion can I just clarify who
where the responsibility would lie for
all the landscaping and all the
conditions
whoever ultimately takes the development
on and brings it Forward they will have
a duty to ensure that they comply with
the planning conditions
very much okay do we have any more
points of clarification councilor Crump
I'll be brief I promise um mentioned by
one of the speakers that one of the
reasons potentially not to Grant this
application is to do with breaches of
conditions can I just clarify that this
is a planning committee and enforcement
is a different part so we're not looking
to do with things that are enforceable
we're looking at the right uh for a plan
and approval but not for the lower
enforceable
ultimately when when a condition
Ed to be
um
a degree of enforceability but that is
in the the triggers and the wording and
obviously if you considered it the the
condition that meets the relevant test
so it's it's supported by policy and it
is ultimately going to
mitigate or or make the development
acceptable then it's appropriate to put
that condition on that there is
obviously an enforcement process and
they are governed by the council's
enforcement plan as to when whether they
take enforcement action it's not for the
the decision maker to make an assessment
at that point as to whether it's
appropriate to put a condition on where
there's an argument that on another site
it wouldn't have been enforced because
ultimately if you are putting the
condition on you are putting it on
because you feel it's appropriate and
then it would be enforced if it wasn't
met
on each individual scheme that comes
forward is that right yes thank you
thank you councilor Crump okay unless
anyone else has a final point of
clarification which I'm going to see him
as a no we'll move into the base let's
move to the debate who would like to
kick us off counts the Kendall first
please
right I've listened with interests
throughout this and I'll be honest I've
gone backwards and forwards or with with
each speaker to be honest with you
for me this is one of those head versus
heart situations
um nobody likes changes to the airport
Countryside no one likes to see things
built or any changes made to you know
green and pleasant land like we have
nobody likes that obviously but at the
same time you've got to be sensible
and I'm looking at this application I'm
thinking well I can't I can't find any
material planning grounds to object I
can't see anything there nothing that's
really strong
um and a mind that sometimes we do have
to modernize we have to move with times
what was a particular country rural
scene 200 years ago would be completely
unrecognizable to people today because
the landscape changes over time and I'm
also satisfied that when it comes to the
visibility of this site that in 15 years
time or 20 years time it will no longer
be as visible and to a certain extent
people will have become used to it it
will have blended into people's idea of
of the countryside and these particular
views
and we need to accept that farming and
energy use changes over time in this
instance I mean look I'm a history
teacher it wasn't so long ago that
people were terrified the seed drill
would put Farm laborers out of work it
would change farming forever well it
didn't people survive farming went on an
improved
if Farms sometimes are going to turn to
solar panels
as a way of supplementing their income
and by the way plugging the Gap in terms
of energy that we desperately need to do
in this country well this is probably a
way of doing it and this is why I asked
my question to Mr Cowper only about his
intentions towards sheep farming on that
plant well I hope he is
um but I think you know that
demonstrates then there would be the
offset you would still be able to use
the land for agricultural purposes as
well as producing a huge amount of
energy
for me heartless head as I've said um
I'll be going with my head making the
sensible choice and with that I will
propose Grant
thank you very much cancer Kendall
councilor Perry next please
thank you chair
um this is a very finely balanced
application
um and like councilor Kendall I've
listened to
um the objectors and also the applicants
agent
um but I've also drilled down to some
policy issues as well
um the things that I don't there is
never any application that comes forward
to us that doesn't does not require a
difficult decision to be made and there
are always pros and cons for any
application that comes before us
certainly one thing that does concern me
is the impact on the residential amenity
of the three cottages
or the small housing unit that is right
adjacent to the solar farm
you then look at the other side of the
balance we have the mppf paragraph 152
um
making sure that we we have to take
positive steps towards renewable energy
we also have our own policy which is CS3
on sustainable energy and in particular
having listened to Mr Cowper one of the
key things on the solar energy what we
have to look at is the impact on
agricultural activities and disturbances
to agricultural land we've had it clear
from
um Mr calper that that land isn't
producing the sort of quality of crops
it should be we're all well aware of the
terribly High increased costs of
fertilizer
so looking from a completely balanced
perspective and I understand the views
of the local community and it is a
balancing act but at this moment in time
I am
um
because of the energy crisis also this
is the third solar farm application that
this committee has had to address in the
last three months I guess
sure it's three months this is actually
the smallest that has come forward the
previous two were 90 hectares and I know
because one was approved in my ward in
new bold Pacey which had a far greater
impact on the medieval village
Conservation area of newborn Pacey and
that got approved and that was
considerably bigger than this
there was another application that got
turned down because of its urbanization
on a small village but I'm looking at
this yes there are downsides but I'm I
am going to be going with the office's
recommendation and I will second
councilor Kendall's proposal
thank you very much councilor Barry
um Council Curtis next please
thank you
I find I disagree very little we've
actually we've got councilor Perry and
kennels have said
but the size of this
despite the fact that it is smaller
because of Perry I accept that
um page 24 of the report
the site being proposed is significantly
larger than the 25 hectares
that should be in this area it's it's
more than double that size and that
really does give me cause for concern
and then and looking back at policy CS5
um you know development takes place in a
manner that minimizes and mitigates its
impact proposals have regard to the
local distinctiveness and character
protect landscape character and avoid
detrimental effects on features and I
think
for me
it is a problem I it's it
this is just Judgment of Solomon these
these applications
um
because it's to me because it's over
double that size and I'm
finding it difficult to support support
the recommendation at the moment
I'm going to assume from what you've
said that you are sitting on the fence
at the moment you are not going to
propose the counter proposal at this
stage lovely thank you Council Crump
next please yeah trying to be brief
again and again it's a very difficult
one
um and again
um I've tried to look at this
dispassionately and that's why I did try
and speak to the agent um the London
and what was pertinent to me is the
actual usage of the land
first the the wheat and the rape is
either being used for ethanol
or on the main in the making of plastics
it doesn't seem to be going towards food
production and pardoned upon pardon the
farming analogy we've got this from the
horse's mouth
so I I think we do need to make sure
we're making decisions on the facts
we've got in front of us
again demand is mainly 3B
when you look at the Quality and the
classifications it's not particularly
great it's okay but not particularly
great if it was 3A or even two I would
be concerned and the other point that
came out is the invasive weed which is
again making this Farm more difficult to
be profitable so then again we move on
to the viability of the farm
so once an added income two there's some
form of diversification going into sheep
farming and therefore they will be
producing actually food
for the country
not ethanol or things for Plastics so
you know it's finally biased but I do
think
the the need for both few Foods outside
fuel Security will be met by this and
potentially food security as well with
sheep grazing and the maintenance
maintaining the viability of a farm
which could potentially go out of
business because it's unprofitable
because of the invasive weed so I will
be supporting the application
[Music]
Council Crump thank you very much
Council Dixon next please
um I did notice on the on the map on
page 35 that the Shakespeare's way just
uh just touches the uh the side of the
crimskirt there so as I walked out
earlier in the year I uh I spotted it
um but nevertheless I am a rambler and
I've often walked from headcut along the
escarpment and uh through Costco
and I have to say that there may be some
solar Farms which can be seen from there
but I didn't notice any
and I think for it to be really
prominent he should have been a blot on
the landscape and I don't think they are
and therefore I will be supporting the
officer's recommendation I think this
one is sufficiently far enough away not
to be an object on the on the landscape
thank you very much
Council of Foreman next please
listen to all of the speakers I've
listened to everything that my fellow
councilors have said and I completely
agree it is a head and heart decision
but I've weighed up everything that's
been said I've written it all down I've
thought about it and I will be
supporting the application
[Music]
thank you very much councilor Mills
thank you chairman yeah I'm just looking
at um page 25 and the second paragraph
um
council's landscape often considers a
proposed development is likely to cause
a significant effect on the landscape
and we go down to the last one uh I I
acknowledge that the application will
cause a level of harm there is harm here
Mr chairman I can't say I'm I'm
all in favor I'm I'm a little bit tall
but I think there is a harm to the
landscape here Mr chairman so um
I'll see what anybody else has to say
thank you
okay thank you very much
um I think that's everyone apart from
myself and councilor Eden I'm not going
to add anything because I think anything
I want to say has been said can I have
anything you want to say if not we'll
move to a cancer curse you've got one
you want to come back one more please if
I made sure we're reminded to approve
um just looking at the older Minister
Parish Council uh requesting condition
if permission granted this is on page
15. pulsing places between the 3400 and
bridge at Winston and provision of a
footpath from Winston to the a3400 there
will be
regrettably if this does go ahead and
it's a very large increase in hgvs down
that stretch of road and currently there
is no footpath
from the a3400 to Winston so I think if
it were to go ahead I think there would
be a safety issue there
if there were no footpath
okay understood
um okay so we we have a proposal uh the
proposal is to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendation made by
councilor Kendall seconded by councilor
Parry
um we will move to that vote could I
please have a show of hands footage in
favor of granting application
2102017 if you want
I make that eight
and those against
two
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application
2102017ful land at crimson
[Applause]
now um I appreciate most people in the
gallery will probably be wanting to go
now so we will take a five minute break
hopefully less than that while everyone
makes them their way out of the building
right okay let's uh let's make a start
shower if that's okay just wait for us
we'll come back live again right okay
I've taken over from Council riches for
a bit so we can move then to item five
on on the agenda tonight this is
application reference uh 22 slash zero
two three one eight slash ful this is
Toad Hall the green center field
Warwickshire uh the description then for
a construction of a stable block an
outdoor riding arena presenting officer
Victoria Kempton over to you thank you
so the application site is located
approximately one kilometers to the
southwest of Smithfield Village Center
and it's marked by the black dot on the
map the land has been assessed has been
in equestrian use which lies in open
Countryside Greenbelt and Arden special
landscape area
in terms of the context the site is an
open path of land where the neighboring
properties include an equestrian
facility to the North Commercial
businesses to the east with barn
conversions and the application dwelling
Beyond whilst the further dwelling and
Bank of Version 9 to the West
finally open Countryside lies to the
South
information is sought for a stable block
and riding arena as indicated on the
site plan which would utilize the
existing field access
the arena would measure 60 meters by 25
meters with a sand and fiber surface and
surrounding Timber post and rail fence
in terms of the floor plan the building
would have six Stables attack room and
hay barn which would be arranged around
a central Courtyard hard standing area
the location plan shows the location of
the Stables
here
and a field shelter here which are to be
removed
[Music]
this site shows the design of the
proposed building which would be
finished with a natural gay gray fiber
cement roof with concrete block Cronk
sorry concrete block work walls and
Timber boarded Windows stable doors will
be present on the inner side of the
building whilst canopy roof would link
the two hearts of the building
in terms of the scale the building would
have a height of 3.5 meters length of
29.8 meters and a width of 13 meters
resulting in a footprint of
approximately 220 square meters when
including the canopies
this slideshow shows the surrounding
context more clearly with the sight
lying here
you can also see how the site acts as a
break in the built form for Road users
as discussed in the report the existing
Stables which are located off gospel oat
Lane are located here
whilst the section of the a46 runs along
here
these photos were taken inside the site
with photo number one looking towards
the development area within neighboring
developments shown in the background
photo number two was taken from near to
the entrance with views to the West with
a highway to the right of the photo
number three was taken in a similar
position to number two showing the
surrounding land to the South which is
opening character providing long
distance views of the development you
can see from this photo how the levels
of the land rise in that direction
foreign
the first photos of you looking to the
site from the green showing the access
to the development it would also show
the Royal character and locality and how
the proposed development would be read
from public Realm
two photos to the right show the four
Stables which are to be removed
[Music]
the application is recommended for
refusal for the reason outlined in the
office's report a member site visit took
place on Monday as listed in the site
update sheet and this concludes my
presentation thank you thank you okay
we've got our first speaker on this
application uh Council Corrine Elliott
from Centerfield Parish Council hello
please excuse my voice to this it's uh
I've got work I've got what's going
around at the moment don't worry
don't worry it's fine take a seat right
well you will you'll have three minutes
um to speak to the committee if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end um I'll give you a warning in the
last 30 seconds if that's okay so you
can you know to wrap up does this switch
on we can already hear you it's perfect
don't worry just speak nicely into the
into the mic
over to you whenever you're ready
okay
the parish council considers it would be
helpful to list all the positive and
compliant family facts confirmed in the
planning report before members
as10 core strategy permits a question
related activities in open Countryside
G6 development requirements SPD
must be of appropriate size for Animal
Welfare
NDP
alw4 protects and enhances Sport and
recreational facilities
and dpb who are responding to local
character the design and the proposed
materials are compatible with the
distinctive character of the area
in addition the development would be
well screened from view by existing
hedgerows and is not unduly forward of
the building line
the density is in keeping with the
character of the surrounding development
in that their existing substantial
equestrian facilities in separate
ownership immediately opposite the site
ndpbe4 designed to reduce crime and
dpin2 drainage and flooding water no
harm in flood zone one
NDP in3 highway safety highways have no
objections
climate change checklist compliant
special landscape area it will not be
harmed
residential immunity not impacted and
support from immediate Neighbors
all the above demonstrates that the
development is acceptable
however core strategy policy CS 10.10
states that any development in the green
belt is harmful unless very special
circumstances are demonstrated to
mitigate the perceived harm
the parish councilor considers that the
applicant has provided sufficient
special circumstances to mitigate the
perceived harm to the green belt
particularly regarding the welfare of
their horses and reducing crime
in addition the applicant has been very
careful to cite the development next to
the built form being the most suitable
location to reduce any impact on the
green belt
Parish Council hopes that members are
minded to support this application
however if support is given the parish
council request conditions that external
lighting is restricted and the existing
four stables and the field shape field
shelter removed
I was just about to give you a 30 second
warning all right thank you very much
okay do you have any questions please
Council Rock uh thank you Chan good
evening
um I I listened carefully to what the
officer said possibly I've misunderstood
it we actually talked about a cement
board finished and then you said the
Finish was completely compatible with
the surroundings
whereas the other uh we went I went on
the site visit and the existing Stables
are sort of clapperboard type thing
could you comment on that if you think
that's appropriate the cement board is
appropriate or have I got that wrong uh
actually I'm not sure about that okay
thank you perhaps question for the
applicant later yeah councilor Perry
nice to see you
um I also attended the site visit
and I noticed there were buildings to
the right of the application site
buildings to the left of the application
site and buildings opposite the
application site
um my question therefore is does the
parish council view the site as infill
as an infill location in view of the the
buildings to the right and the left
and opposite yes I mean it could
possibly be seen as in Phil yes thank
you
okay so no further questions one more
sorry counselor and thank you
um you mentioned uh that the parish
council would like to see
um be assured that the lighting wasn't
going to be intrusive and the the
existing Stables would be removed yeah
where are the applicants happy with
colors as far as they know the
applicants are happy with that but I'm
sure they'll fill you in when they're
coming thank you
okay oh councilman's Publishers thank
you
um at the moment the the horses are
stabled on the there's two Stables I
could I could see
um
with this new
um
Equestrian Center would it be more
obviously be more secure than what's
there already because that's right next
to the node isn't it totally more secure
the new or question yeah yes intended
yeah definitely
um and that's part of the um I say about
crime uh complies with uh
ndpb for teenagers Khan thank you thank
you in that case I think thank you very
much from the committee as well you can
return now to your previous seat thank
you we'll go to our next um speaker then
which is Steve Bromley the agent for the
Appleton Laura Turner the applicant
herself
we have three minutes uh how do you want
to break this down between the two of
you we're going to uh share the three
minutes it's not very long I'm just
going to make a very brief introduction
and then hand it over to Laura whatever
that's fantastic we have three minutes
over to you
yes thank you chairman this is the
second application we have submitted and
represents a reduction in the size of
the building from the first application
we welcome that officers have sought to
negotiate however an additional
reduction in the size of the building by
removing two bays would make no
discernible difference to preserving the
openness of the green belt now
interestingly on page 43 third paragraph
I'd ask you to note that the planning
officers consider the development is
acceptable with regard to landscape
impact
so I'll hand over with Laura at that
point good evening I'm Laura Turner I'm
with my family we moved into toad Hall
in September last year I thank you for
the opportunity to briefly talk on my
planning application uh born on a farm
horses have always been part of my life
and for my daughter the same is true she
has chosen a career working with horses
having completed a equine degree at
University
she works locally for Dan Skelton and
Gina Ellis and she exercises trains and
competes her own two horses her be
record which is mentioned in the report
would show these competitions but if you
add in unaffiliated events the locally
run cops World Cup show jumping dressage
and Pony Club competitions we're out at
30 plus events a year it's a huge huge
commitment when we assess what
facilities did exist at toad Hall we
used criteria of suitability as it
related to the equine welfare pair of
the six horses we do own security of
ground maintenance equipment and horse
tap personal safety and sustainability
there are just a few insights I want to
share with you the two old ponies we do
keep are in the existing past their end
of life Stables that have been pointed
out on the map these are probably
approximately 400 meters from the house
and directly off gospel Oak Lane which
is approximately 50 meters from the a46
at 2 A.M in the morning when the ponies
are ill and I go to check on them having
had the BET out I feel very vulnerable
as our application States there's no
electricity and sadly on numerous
occasions Vans or cars do stop in that
Gateway and use it as a toilet there's
no getting around that on sustainability
the 300 plus bales of hay from the
grassland this summer we were only able
to keep 50 because we have nowhere to
store them 30 seconds oh on security we
have no track to Harrow or roller Tap
Room is now a concrete line to stop
thieves breaking in we have nowhere to
keep the tap and equipment so in summary
as a family we want to responsibly
provide quality facilities for the six
horses we do own and collectively bring
them back to the proposed development
thank you
with six seconds to spare thank you okay
any questions from the committee please
Council Rock and Council I've gone first
again
nice to see your agent today
um
um I'm going to ask a second question
and I'll probably ask the officers this
as well it says in here officers sort
and negotiate Amendment it's in it
sounds like that was reduction in size
but it's the finish that I'm interested
in did that negotiation include the
Finish
uh and uh if there's if it's cement
board which it appears to be uh would it
not be better in some natural material
that Accords more with the uh the green
belt Etc and and would you be uh
interested in a condition
that's suggested a different finish
well um I mean obviously you can you can
speak to the planning officer but we
were never requested to change the
materials and in fact it's it's concrete
block work which is it's the same
material as the large building on the
opposite side of the lane the very large
building it's exactly the same materials
so it sort of matches into those okay
got my answer thank you chairman thank
you Council Crump
okay we couldn't arrange for better
weather when we went on the side visit
yeah I think we've just about dried our
front we get into the Rocks here so uh
um
obviously what struck me there was one
um the location being far away it was
uphill passed those mole Hills and I
could imagine that's quite challenging
walking there in the pit till I am
um what you mentioned you got six horses
uh six
um policies of mixed up horses and
pounds so I do apologize
um would that enable this new block
enable you to staple them all together
yes so they're currently spread out the
the two that were there of the two old
ponies you know of this height
um three are twice the size you know
five foot eight five foot nine to the
shoulder with a head beyond that
um they're currently stable stable
locally and there's one we moved from
heart there's one that still remains in
Hertfordshire so this would be
consolidating them all
um into the proposed development which
is why I was very keen to continue with
the six stable application
you would return to Council Rock and I
when you mentioned the two old terms
thank you okay any further questions
counselor Perry
good evening
um I I was just interested to know
whether the
um whether any potential plans for
economic development from if if you if
you were successful in in getting this
um
application granted and in terms of
would there be any jobs
um arising from such a facility so
we we talked about this and it's it's
it's our personal it's personal use I'm
not looking at running a business or
incurring business rates
um so you know very much
um they would be looked after by us so
I'm I'm not sure if that's the right
answer to say I don't envisage it would
be a job but as I say I'm not looking to
take on board running a business and the
necessary insurance and everything that
goes with that in employing people
that's fine yeah councilor Harvey
um
I wonder if you could say something
about the threat of crime locally
um I think it's a powerful reason you've
put forward in justification it would
help me to understand the threat if you
could say something about other thefts
from of tech although have there been
incidents of car theft locally assaults
or whatever I'm just trying to get a
sense of how real that threat although
it's I I I accept the perception of the
of threat is is real I'd like to know if
you've got any experience of actual
crime in the area so our neighbors have
their Range Rover stolen two months ago
so um that's a very real happened very
locally
um I I read I read about rural crime I
see you know the recommendations for the
tack rooms having the concrete ceilings
where we keep the horses at the moment
you know there's that I think she had an
incident and she now has a caged
environment within the tap room to stop
the tap being stolen so I haven't got
specific crime figures but I could um
you know for the area or for the
postcode but it um I see quad bikes
stolen
um Etc next door is pretty close though
yes next door was Carl was close
thank you any other questions
in that case thank you both very much
for your time
I will just before we invite what member
just to remind members that obviously we
don't have you know what's called
substantiated figures the crime levels
in the area we only have all the
applicants told us no reason not to
believe you but I just need to point
that out
right uh board member you're already
here good evening councilor it's just
you have five minutes over to you thank
you very much uh members I'd like to
start by thanking those of you who
braved the wind and the rain on Monday
it wasn't pleasant for any of us um but
thank you very much that I hope you
found it useful I'm really grateful for
your uh your attendance you'll know from
the officers report that the key reason
in essence is a green belt reason for
refusal you'll also know that the
fundamental purpose of the green belt
are set out in paragraph 137 of the mppf
is to prevent urban sprawl
it goes on to provide exceptions to
Green Belt policy in paragraph 149 which
is supported by our own core strategy
cs10 and specifically identifies the
following as exemptions
Limited infill in villages
limited infill or partial or complete
Redevelopment of previously developed
land and the provision for appropriate
facilities for outdoor Sport and
Recreation provided of course it
preserves the openness of the green lot
failing that special circumstances would
be required one can comfortably argue
that one or all of those exemptions
apply to the proposed development site
to the northwest of the site so directly
opposite lives Avon cross stud farm and
equestrian facility to the north east of
the site lies a combination of
commercial and residential buildings and
to the Southwest lies a further
residential property
the site itself is the current home to a
number of horses whose stable blocks are
proposed to be removed as part of this
application to my mind this clearly fits
the definition of infill and the partial
Redevelopment of previously developed
land it is also clear that the proposal
is for an equestrian use and as such is
supported as a provision for outdoor
sports and recreation indeed this latter
point is confirmed by the case officer
who in a reason for refusal identifies
that the proposal is for outdoor Sport
and Recreation
she does go on to say that in her
opinion The Proposal would not preserve
the openness of the green belt
that is subjective and to my mind the
proposal would preserve the openness of
the green belt particularly given the
existing stable blocks are to be removed
those of you who attended the site visit
will know that the landslopes away from
the a46 and down towards the sighting of
The Proposal that has the effect of
reducing the impact of The Proposal on
the openness of the green belt but also
moves the horses closer to the existing
equestrian first facility at avoncraft
stud farm and crucially away from the
a46
that has the effect clearly of improving
the animal's welfare
so to my mind this proposal should be
supported as an exemption to the
Greenbelt policy either because it
represents it limited infill in our
Villages or because it represents
limited infill of previously developed
land for the same use or because it
represents an appropriate facility for
outdoor sports and recreation and for
the reasons I've set out the proposal
does preserve the openness of the green
belt however if you disagree with me on
any of those The Proposal can be
supported with special circumstances
we've already heard about prevention of
crime I'll add to that that the land is
previously developed for the same use
the existing and question facilities
have come to the end of their useful
life and are no longer adequate to save
to safely house horses and the sighting
of The Proposal brings the horses away
from the a46 and gospel Oak Lane
improving the animals welfare but also
the safety of other Road users
members I trust you'll agree with me
that this proposal is appropriate for
its rural location it does not represent
urban sprawl all the merging of villages
it represents one of three exemptions
I've set out and that it does not
impinge on the openness of the green
belt with Parish Council support Ward
member support no objections from
statutory consultees or neighbors I
trust you are able to support this
application too thank you very much
thank you
um any questions for the ward member
thank you very much okay
let's see
um okay so um any uh we're good points
of clarification do we have any
questions for the officer Council Dix
IE thank you chairman Victoria
um on page 42 halfway down we've got
officers sought to negotiate amendments
to the scheme I think we heard from
Steve Bromley that there was a
suggestion of a reduction in the number
of units being combined there
if they had as it were acceded to that
would the recommendation be different
um I can't say what the recommendation
would be without seeing plans
um but the the issues with the current
application is due to its scale
um we did also seek amendments we've
gone exciting
um as well
um but we'd have to view a case upon
submission if it was smaller but it
would certainly reduce the home okay
councilor up that's the second question
was already asked twice but our house
the officers about the Finish
is it possible to condition something to
do with the Finish to make it more
appropriate to the location so we
mitigate any harm to the setting
if if the committee was marketed to
Grant it
it's listed on the plans as I understand
it in theory you could do a
notwithstanding so not withstanding
details on the approved plans regarding
materials they could be
um submitted
um prior to the commencement of
development or consideration obviously
if counselors were minded to approve and
were minded to put a condition of that
nature on
as it would be a pre-commencement
condition it would have to be agreed by
the applicants but that could be
delegated to officers to do
um
thank you chairman thank you officers
any other questions our points of
clarification I should say
wow okay let's go to the debate let's
start off
counselor
[Laughter]
um
I think I'm quite comfortable that this
as that one by councilor Richards is
kind of in Phil and absolutely
definitely for sports and recreation so
I'll be very very keen to support this
application I think so I'm happy to
propose that if someone would like to
back me up on that fantastic we'll go to
capsule Rock uh yes I I find I'm in
agreement with uh councilor Richard's uh
explanation uh and I'm happy to support
what canceled and said but I'm concerned
about two things uh one is light
pollution which has been mentioned in
here so if we were to approve it I would
like to see a condition about external
lighting
um
uh so there is no nuisance lighting and
I think we have a standard condition for
that and secondly I think we've heard
that it is possible to do something
about the uh the finish uh I'm not
suggesting we change the block work but
at least we do something to buy
negotiation to ensure he's not intrusive
we don't end up with a white cement
block in the middle of the field and I'm
not quite sure what we can do but I
defer to offices and on the Assumption
we can deal with that by condition I I
would um I'm afraid disagree with the
officers recommendation and propose we
support it
so was that formally seconding yes thank
you just checking
um okay we go to cats Parry Ben Mills
thank you chair
um
it's
Green Belt applications are always very
interesting
um and they calls us all to make sure we
do our own homework revisiting the mppf
revisiting our own policies
um but I do feel on this occasion
um I'm not surprised that the parish
council
um are supporting this application we
have a situation where we haven't got
any any objections
um what to me is really crucial is is
personal safety in particular
um and also the safety and Welfare of
the horses
um I take on board councilor rocks
um concern about lighting however I
think it's very important there is some
element of security lighting because if
a member of the family has to go out at
night then there needs to be some form
of security lighting
um we're all keen on Dark Skies and I
know councilor rock is a great advocate
of that from a building perspective I'm
actually perfectly happy with what is
proposed in the in the application
because actually it sits very
um well with the equestrian facility
opposite which was the thinking behind
and then I think actually if it was to
come forward with a with some form of
cladding in wood or something it would
actually stand out more
um and it would have a a a larger impact
on the landscape so I I'm very happy to
support this application but as is with
without
um interference to a change in the
construction materials I also feel it's
it's definitely infill from my
perspective as a committee we have
you know put residential buildings on
infill sites this is clearly infill
um it supports agricultural it promotes
um personal safety and reduces crime so
fully in support
thank you Council Mills thank you yes
um I agree it's I can see no substantial
harm here
um one of the things is it will improve
the welfare of the horses
um you know stuck right on the the edge
of the youth field there in which you
can easily be stolen or whatever
um but yeah I can't see any significant
harm here and I have to say that
councilor Cohen Elliott did a quite a
convincing report there so uh thank you
for that so
unfortunately unfortunately I'll be
against these officer's recommendations
Mr chairman I will be supporting thank
you
I think so does anybody else wish to
come in here it's Council Dixon thank
you chairman
um Greenbelt infill built up area
boundaries uh the thing that Springs to
my mind and this is not in a built-up
area boundary uh therefore it's
stretching uh the definition to a
certain extent but nevertheless I can
see other merits in this application
thank you chairman thank you very much
councilor Harvey
where the site visit was extremely
important
um to see the map flat on on a page is
one thing to see the ground is is quite
another and I think the the biggest
Factor was the slope from top to bottom
this application will get rid of
um the existing uh Stables which I think
is a is a distinct benefit
um the question of infill is to some as
Council Paris mentioned can sometimes be
a matter of degree
um I can think of instances where there
are quite considerable distances between
properties it would be difficult to
argue that it was infill in this
instance given the setting given the
purpose I don't have any difficulty I
feel sorry for the officer that I
understand why she made her
recommendation but I'm with the majority
of the committee I'll support this
okay
um should we try and sum up um I've had
a quick chat over here I think what
we're trying to say and I'm going to go
to our proposal and second to see if
he's happy with this I think what we're
saying is we feel this is in line with
the exceptions to cs10 in that we do
think this is there's no harm to the
openness of the open Countryside in
regards to be a form of agricultural
infill
um is that wording acceptable do you
need more than vertical I think
obviously the the definition of infill
relates to infill in villages obviously
this isn't within a village however from
what councilors have been saying I've
I've noted that when you've discussed
the matter of the infill you're talking
about the the equestrian is opposite and
the fact that that leads you to think
that there's no harm you've also noted
that this the site soaps up so I'm I'm
what I'm taking from that is that
because of the location or that you
don't feel that there's any harm to the
character an openness of the green belt
am I correcting that's what you've been
I think a lot of nods rather than I'll
go accounts ready because you proposed
it and you're happy with it
same sort of thing only thing is I I it
sounds like we may not be content of the
lighting condition and I'll just point
out the councilor Parry the lighting
condition doesn't preclude as doing
something with security lighting it's
approach it can be considered by the
officers at the time but we don't want
flood lights on all the time but I think
reactive lighting is one thing I think
that's what I don't know where you know
if there's no support for trying to do
something with the appearance of the
building we will we will act on the good
officers of the applicant not to do
something that's outrageous no doubt
they won't so I will withdraw that uh
suggestion if that's what that's helpful
so if we withdraw that but we then go to
the next set which is do we have a set
of standard conditions because you can
see which way this is going and I'm
guessing lighting will be one of those
conditions
foreign
prepared a couple of conditions we
thought councilors might want to include
obviously we've got the standard time
standard plans and the materials to be
in accordance with the plans because
they are detailed on the plans
um we've also
um acknowledged that the location plan
indicates that there are Stables that
would be removed so we would have a
condition on that they would be
um removed as identified on the location
plan and and we've also included a
condition that the building and riding
arena to be used solely for private
recreational purposes
um in keeping with what has been
proposed as part of the application no
waste to be burnt on any part of the
application site and that there are a
number of conditions in respect of the
development should not be occupied until
the vehicular access and vehicle turning
area
um and obviously words could be
dedicated to officers to finalize the
actual details of that but it's in
respect of um Vehicles not um leaving
and re-entering the public highway so
they should be leaving and re-entering
in a forward gear sorry
um and then also prior to the erection
um installation of any external lighting
so we have included that um details of
the external lighting to be submitted
and approved in writing and we've also
asked we would also ask I should say as
part of that
um details to include things like the
the equipment supporting structures
positions
um sizes Heights the light intensity
illumination so it would help with um
some of the concerns that were raised in
regard to that it also matters like
hours of lighting
um and then obviously a climate change
checklist was submitted in sport the
application so that would be included
and then there would also be a couple of
standard informatives that we look to
include which is the nppf positive
practice statement and the nesting bird
statement and I believe highways also
requested an informative
um regarding the visibility space
is there anything else that counts this
bill
I think that's pretty exhaustive list
actually so I'm I'm content I'm getting
a lot of Knowledge from around the room
right well we've got our reasons we've
set those out we've got a set of
conditions we have a proposal which then
seconded should we go to the vote
so the proposal then is to Grant this in
line with everything that's been said
tonight and the conditions attached all
those in favor please show
I don't need to count you know so
therefore committee resolves to Grant
application reference
22-2-318 ful and I will vacate the chair
and invite Council Richards back
okay
we've lost Trevor
ladies gents we we it is eight o'clock
now we have two more applications to get
through according to Constitution we've
got to start the second one before eight
o'clock
um unless we all agree and discretion
but we need to focus on this so sorry 8
30. I should have said not eight o'clock
because it is eight o'clock now
um okay so our next application is uh
2202164 ful that's traded in hillbounds
in trading internships on staff
um our presenting offer is Stewart's
divers sure whenever you're ready over
to you
thank you
foreign
yeah thank you chairman
so the proposal that is before members
is for demolition of two agricultural
buildings and the erection of a new
dwelling so you have the location plan
here in front of you you can see the
site itself is denoted by a black dot
here
so we have the fossway which runs uh
North South directly adjacent to the
sides
as you can see the site is centered
surrounded by open Countryside
approximately 1.5 kilometers South
Southwest of trennington and you have a
footpath which runs to the west of the
site and then running to the north
[Music]
and then we have another a picture of
the site plan here so you have you can
see that the site itself is with the red
line area denoted here and you have the
agricultural Barn which is to be
demolished here
and then uh opposite the application
site and adjacent to the fox where you
have a electricity distribution site
[Music]
and then we just have an aerial image
here again you can see the red line area
outlined in red here and again you can
see the larger agricultural bomb which
is to be demolished here
so there is an extant a mission on site
to convert the existing larger
agricultural building into into two
dwellings under class Q of the general
permitted development order
[Music]
and then we just go on to a proposed
site plan here so this is the proposed
dwelling as you can see here as you can
see it has a fairly simple rectilinear
form
um adjacent to the site
um which might be quite difficult to see
for members on the screen but there is a
red dashed outline which is the
footprint of the existing Barn
and then we just go on to some of the
proposed elevations here
um and as you can see that you've got a
front elevation here so this will face
towards the fossway
um as you can see uh from the south
elevation the proposed Welling has a
fairly simple shallow dual pitched form
uh in terms of height the height of the
dwelling is 6.6 meters which is 300
millimeters taller than the existing
agricultural building on site
just to give it a bit of context and
comparison again it might not be too
easy to see on the screen but you have a
green dashed outline here so this is the
outline of the proposed dwelling which
was
um
close to running out the site that was
previously refused by members at
committee back in April
and then we just have some more
elevations here of the proposed dwelling
in terms of the material palette we've
got uh concrete render standing scene
cladding and Native Timber cladding
[Music]
and then we just go on to the approved
elevations of the fallback position here
[Music]
and now we just get on to some images of
the site so this image is from the layby
which is directly adjacent to the Foss
way so we're looking into the site and
you have the large rack of cultural bar
which is to be demolished here
and then we have another site image so
this is just from within the application
site again looking towards uh the
agricultural Barn facing away from Fox
way
and then we go on to uh so these are
certain Google street images uh street
view image images so this is facing to
the North and then you have the lay by
here so you can just sort of see the
access here and the site is off to the
right
and then we have another Google Street
View image which is looking South
and then you have the application site
just off off the screen to the left-hand
side here uh just helps to give a bit of
context in terms of the boundary
vegetation
so in summary the proposed demolition of
the two agricultural Barns and the
erection of the new dwelling does not
comply with the relevant provisions of
policy as10 in terms of residential
development however relevant to the
decision is the existence of a full-back
position to convert the larger
agricultural buildings to two dwellings
officers consider this to be of material
relevance in the assessment of this
application and significant way to be
afforded this fallback position weighs
in favor of the post-dwelling and as
such it is recommended the planning
permission is grounded thank you
chairman
sure thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is councilor Harvey
speaking on behalf of tredington Parish
Council
Harvey you're very well versed in how
this works so three minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're set and
comfortable oh I'm speaking on you're
speaking on behalf of trading and Parish
Council right now I'm not speaking to
him thank you
okay
that makes life a little bit easier
um okay in that case we'll call our next
speaker on the item who is Dan Pierce
and Piers Brooks I have here good
evening gentlemen and welcome
now I've got you down for three minutes
I'll give you 30 second warning are you
is one of you going to speak in the
other two questions yeah that's correct
I'm going to speak and then here's the
questions okay in that case I'll give
you a 30 second warning whenever your
second conference ready to go
good evening everyone my name is Dan
Pierce here on behalf of my wife and I
for this application to build a forever
home after my wife moved locally for
work
following on from the planning office's
comments I reiterate we address the
cited previous reasons for rejection in
full
there's a considerable reduction in
height there's a simplified built form
and site layout with a less contemporary
material palette to represent a modern
agricultural Barn in keeping with the
existing character
this new application has a 22 reduction
in volume compared to the class Q eight
percent reduction in glazing and
restrictions on urbanization and
domestication through the cartilage
controls
and I want to address some of the
content of the objection letters for
this application
I can confirm that we're not looking to
mislead the members there is a 22
reduction in volume the smaller second
Bonds on site that is not part of the
class queue approval is included is not
included in this value
the planning officers report supports
this application is betterment to the
existing with respect to ecology
biodiversity landscape and climate
change
we have modified the appearance in
response to the committee's feedback
with a smaller volume smaller footprint
less contemporary appearance like a
cultural character and restrictions in
place to prevent any domestication
I also want to draw the committee to the
existing precedence and planning
consistency and continuity with other
approved applications utilizing the
class queue fallback listed in the
office's report a net reduction of
dwellings is of material relevance
the property is half a kilometer from
the nearest footpath with all views
screened due to the Topography of the
Land There Are No long distance views of
the barn it is glimpsed briefly from the
existing axis
the highways Department raises no
objection and the access to the property
is that under existing grant for the
class queue
therefore in conclusion we fully agree
with the officer's report and
recommendation for approval significant
weight should be afforded to the class
queue fullback position and that this
proposed development is considered less
harmful and more sustainable than the
existing fullback in terms of design
character landscape ecology biodiversity
and sustainability
consideration must be given to planning
decision consistency and continuity with
previous applications
under the exact same circumstances using
the class queue fullback together with
enforceable betterment conditions
therefore we respectfully request
permission is granted for this amended
proposal
marvelous thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions either for our applicant or
for his architects
no in that case both of you thank you
very much for your time and
contributions this evening thank you of
course your patience as well
this time we will hear from councilor
Harvey
Council Harvey then once you're settled
and ready you'll have five minutes with
your 30 second warning use as much of
that time as you wish
um as soon as you're settled
the floor is yours
thank you chairman there's marriage in
the principle of redundant agricultural
buildings most notably disused barns
having their useful lives prolonged by
their conversion to residences
inappropriate circumstances and settings
the provision of the possibility of a
conversion under a class Q application
was intended just for this purpose it
was not provided as a backdoor route to
the building of a new residence in the
open Countryside
but for the extent extent extension
class Q consent in this instance this
application would certainly be refused
because it would be a building devoid of
any exceptional quality or design
characteristics neither would it make
any positive contribution to the
character of the local area as such it
would fail to comply with the council's
relevant policy designated to protect
the open Countryside as-10
there is no expressed local support for
this application not a single resident
has written to support it the parish
council has repeated its objection as it
did in relation to the preceding
application and has done so for similar
reasons the application is not made in
response to a local housing needs survey
the accommodation to provide meets no
local need neither for someone employed
in any form of agricultural job nor in
any related field
the case officer sets out is reasons why
the fallback position in this case is a
material consideration I agree with him
arguably this is the only consideration
that could possibly save this
application from refusal
similarly I agree with him that it's up
to the members of the committee to use
their own judgment in deciding what
weight they should attach to the full
back position amongst their
considerations the committee did just
that when it used its judgment in
relation to the preceding application
for the for the Demolition and
Redevelopment of these two barns and
refused that application
the relevant question seems to be there
for does the committee conclude that the
fallback position would cause greater
harm than the scheme proposed or put it
another way the committee would need to
be satisfied that there were betterments
in planning terms of the proposed scheme
over the extent class Q scheme and
preferably more than one if it were to
be granted this if this application were
to be granted just what are those
betterments in this case as the local
representative of the cpre points out
there's little to choose in terms of
appearance between the proposed house
and the barn that it might replace
in his design and access statement the
applicant's agent points to only one
single betterment not in connection with
the proposed dwelling itself but in
relation to the landscape of the site he
points for instance to the retention of
all existing trees and hedges on the
site
is retention of the status quo the best
betterment to which the agent can draw
the committee's attention
despite his recommendation the doubts
that the case officer has about this
application are demonstrated first by
his recommendation that there is a need
to restrict the cartilage of the site so
severely because of the danger of the
further encroachment of residential
paraphernalia into the open Countryside
the question it is difficult to avoid is
if this application were granted just
how in practice would such a restricted
cartilage be enforced in the longer term
second the case officer's doubts are
demonstrated by his view that the
applicant's permitted development rights
should be removed because of the risk of
further domestication of the site and
undue harm being caused to the open
Countryside why would the case officer
want either of these conditions other
than because he recognizes the
sensitivity of this rural location
the applicant's agent makes something of
the barn-like appearance of the proposed
dwelling this is intended to single
signal a virtue in the application
why should why settle for a barn-like
building however when there's an extent
class queue permission for the
conversion of a real Bond if this
application were to be granted it would
cause greater harm than the
implementation of the class Q consent
because the domesticating intrusion of
the surrounding area into the open
Countryside despite the intended
condition would in reality be physically
greater than the alternative if the cpre
observation on the appearance of the
alternative bonds is on offer is
accurate why would the committee not
conclude that the less harmful extent
class Q consent can and should be
implemented on this basis therefore Mr
chairman I urge the committee to refuse
the application thank you
I don't know how I managed to say the 30
seconds just before people stop but
there we are thank you very much
councilor Harvey members do we have any
questions for our Ward member please
um
counselor Harvey you did say that there
were no support from uh local residents
on this not that I'm aware of but I
can't see any objections on here from
prison so nobody's lodged objection and
they I looked through the report
nobody's lodged an objection that's been
done through the parish council
but no residence no resident that I know
of
like can I can I add
I mean you've answered the question if
it's related to the question you can add
but if it's not related then no
there's a contrast between this
application and the previous application
that's all I'll say
okay anyone else have any other
questions for Council Harvey
no in that case Council Harvey thank you
very much indeed
okay we have no speakers no further
speakers I should say on this item so do
we have any points of clarification for
our officers
councilor Parry please
excuse me sorry
can you just advise
um if I'm right and thinking it's fairly
normal for permitted development rights
to be removed for class Q
permissions so on the previous uh on the
extent
permission without the writing thing
that PD rights have also been removed on
that one so there's there's no
differential in terms
and it will be normal therefore
for this to come forward with PG rights
removal the board member was suggesting
that the PD rights were being removed
because you were concerned about
further sprawl of the um proposed
dwelling in in due course
um I haven't got
[Music]
um
the conditions for the class here in
front of me obviously each application
has a specialized merits but uh kind of
as you say it's not unheard of for
dwellings dwellings in close proximity
to a country's aside for uh offices to
recommend for PD rides to be removed
[Music]
give me a moment to clarify I think it
could be a case we don't remove it
because within the gpdo there are
certain things that you can't
um do under committed development if
you've had certain prior approvals so we
could check the decision notice for the
prior approvals just to check whether
that's on there if you want us to that's
okay I think that would be helpful I
think you've said is correct
um while you're doing that we're going
to ask for other people to ask their
questions so can somebody else did you
have one okay thank you
um
could you put up on the screen the um
the proposed development
which I think that's
shows
that's it isn't it so
at the moment that's three did what is
the height of it it's 6.6 meters yeah
and the previous one was uh the previous
dwelling uh that was refused at
committee or do you mean the uh
it was
I haven't got the exact measurement in
front of me but I'm pretty sure it was
over 80 meters
um I've got what might be helpful is so
these are the elevations of the previous
okay I refused dwelling okay
thank you could you bring up the image
you had before yeah I can't yeah go
it's worth it's worth pointing out the
um the green hatch line I know it's very
difficult to see on this yeah but that
that I believe and you clarified that as
the it's the refused application that's
the outline yeah yeah
um just a question about clarification
over waste collection I noticed the I
mean highways have made my objection
there's no response from District
Council waste and recycling
is do you know if there's sufficient
room for a bin Lorry to actually pull in
off the road onto the site to collect
bins
uh I'm I haven't I I I'm not wouldn't be
able to give an answer to that myself
um
as you say highways can't Council
highways were console as partly
application and didn't sort of raise any
objection or concern with regard to
there's no no response it's just that
that road is really fast and you get
some very dangerous driving along it
people doing ridiculous things and if a
bin Lorry can't actually pull in
to to the to the land itself I think
there could be a real thing over there
actually sorry I'm speculating yeah yeah
yeah
um
the risk of going into debate one also
has to bear in mind that there are
already two dwellings approved through
the class queue so there'd be more bins
double the amount
um but I believe you should do with that
as you wish
um any other questions uh poets
clarification if not we'll have an
answer for councilor Paris question in
momentarily I think yes
yeah within the gpdo
um the
obviously I can't go through every item
but but generally permitted development
rights that are afforded to householders
in terms of extensions and alterations
um it's specifically cited that if
permission to use the dwelling house as
a dwelling house has been granted by
virtue of class
a number of classes but including class
Q of part three of the gpdo which this
site has the benefit of they cannot
undertake those work so ultimately the
gpdo takes away their limited
development rights in the same way
they're finding application will for the
condition
lovely thank you very much indeed I
don't think there are any more points of
clarification so we will move into
debate who would like to kick us off
councilor rock thank you chairman
um I'd find on in complete agreement
with the ward member
um
obviously we're we're entering a very
technical debate about the fallback
position
but just because it's a bit smaller
than the barn conversion would have been
I I don't believe that's an improved
uh level of harm
this is an agricultural building in the
countryside where agricultural buildings
are found now we're proposing
uh
oh let's call it a normal house a normal
dwelling in the open Countryside which
are all our policies
resist
the argument is
we can take a class Q building which is
highly restricted is a highly restricted
form of Prior notice which isn't
actually a planning permit that
permission as I understand it it's an
exception of Prior notice which is very
restrictive you can't do change Windows
you can't change roof Heights you can't
change walls all that sort of thing if
we're now saying when we've got a class
queue that's permitted we can now turn
it into a dwelling that is quite
different I think there's a real problem
with that and I I think that represents
harm to our district and I think it
represents harm in this particular case
so I would I would propose this this
application is refused for the reason
it's a different judgment but I don't
believe the fullback position uh makes
it less harmful I think it makes it more
harmful because it's a completely
different dwelling to that that would be
permitted under class q and uh uh I
would propose refuse it chairman thank
you thank you very much councilor Parry
please
thank you chair
um
they're always there they always put one
of these applications to sort of try out
to test us don't they
um the big issue I've got I actually I
actually don't like it but my my biggest
issue is that if committee were minded
to refuse
it would go to appeal and we've got
quite a lot of evidence
of the strength and the weight that
needs to be given to the fallback
position and I think
that's my big concern because yeah I
don't like it
but I but I I can see this would get
allowed at appeal because the evidence
and the officer has clearly done his
homework
um and therefore it is not that I want
to do it but I I'm gonna have to go with
the officer's recommendation because of
what is the the strength and the weight
that we do have to give the full back
position thank you chair thank you
councilor just so I can confirm is that
a proposal to Grant thank you very much
councilor Mills next please yeah um I'm
just um
the applicants seem to have gone quite a
long way to uh to come you know comply
with uh
the problems with the objections from
the the last proposal
um I'd say the
the officers came to go a long way and
it's a very good report so I I will go
with um
the opposite of recommendation on this
Jim thank you just to confirm is that a
formal second thing
thank you very much
anyone else councilor Adam was in first
I've changed my mind as I do
um I think Council Rock makes a good
point
um
it it concerns me that it becomes a very
wide open door for anybody to turn a
class queue potentially
into something that's very different and
for that reason I I think I'd support
councilor Rock's proposal as well should
it go that way
um just so I can confirm is that a
performance happening yes yes right I'm
going to try and convince you the other
way now no I have got cancer Dixon uh
lined up speak but if you don't mind I'm
going to dive in before you just because
I want to address that
um
I don't disagree with the sentiment of
what both Council Rock and cancer Edmond
have said
I think what you said Council Rock was
we what we're saying is that you can get
a class queue and then convert it we
aren't saying that I think National
policy and case law is saying that
that's where the difference is I can't
say that I like the idea that one could
get a class queue and then apply to have
it changed because it's not more harmful
but the reality that is case law we
can't change that certainly not sat
around this table so we have to be
mindful of that what councilor paria
said I think is absolutely spot on
um where we have to make decision here
is do we think what is put in front of
us is more harmful than the fullback
position which is the class queue the
reality is it exists a form the fallback
position so is it more harmful I don't
think it is the reason I don't think it
is is because it very much looks like
um a uh a barn like the existing barn
but what councilor Harvey said cpre
their comment was there is little to
choose between the current and the
proposed
that to me says there's no harm because
there's little to choose I actually
think this design is better than the uh
the class queue that's my personal view
but that's a subjective one so hopefully
I've convinced you the other way we'll
find out in a minute
um Council Dixon sorry for taking the
Limelight away from you over to you no
problem
um I think one of the aspects that also
appears under various appeal decisions
is the likelihood of the classical
actually going ahead
and I think the applicant has indeed
shown exactly what he wants
he wants a family home he said his wife
moved to the area he said a good job and
what have you I don't think he wants two
dwellings I don't think he wants to
actually implement the park you he wants
a new dwelling in the open Countryside
and therefore I am not giving much
Reliance to the fact that there is a
fallback position because I don't think
he actually wants to implement it so I'm
with councilors rock counselor Eden
okay that's understood um I just remind
you that the class queue is in fact
extant which means that material style
has already been made whether they
oh no I just got that advice and I'm
being told that's not good okay
no I said
I'll take that back
a slight miscommunication possibly on my
part we don't know but there we are
um okay I'll take it back
Castle Foreman
I'm just referring to the training that
we did last week
um the appeals training and in that one
of the things that we were told was that
significant weight needs to be given to
the fallback position when considering
an application so I am in agreement with
councilor parry and councilor Mills and
I will be supporting the application
marvelous thank you very much indeed I
think we've pretty much covered everyone
the rest of going over the same old
ground I think we've probably move to a
boat so we the first proposal we got um
was from councilor Parry to grant that
was seconded by councilor Mills we will
take that one first so could I please
have a show of hands version in favor of
granting
four those against
three and abstentions
oh God I thought that's all three then
for a second two marvelous okay so
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application 2202 164 ful that is
trettington Hill Barnes in tredington
thank you very much let's move to our
final item with two minutes to spare
um okay our next item is application
reference
2201203 very as land adjacent to the uh
chinnaries in prior's Hardwick
and our presenting officer is Atlantica
Agnew Atlantica will be with us in just
a second as soon as you're ready and set
to go feel free to start
okay
good evening commissee so the
application site is located in the pack
sorry is located in the village of prize
Hardwick and is marked by black circle
on this map
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the site is located to
the north of the village along church
end and immediately off Welsh Road to
the Northeast
the application site lies adjacent to
and shares its eastern and southern
boundary with the prize Hardwick
Conservation Area
[Music]
the application seeks planning
permission for a section 73 application
which would vary the previously approved
scheme granted on the 5th of October
2020.
the applicant is Seeking a variation
condition
is Seeking a variation of conditions to
approved plans three material schedule
four sample panel of stone work five
Landscaping works as during the
construction of the dwelling adjustments
were made including alterations in
fenestration positioning the inclusion
of leaded Dormers Ironstone mullian
willendose with steel casements the Lux
Windows black in color an amended design
to the porch on the North elevation
removal of roof lights to the front and
side elevations the construction of a
brick and stone wall and an amended
Landscaping scheme
here we can see the approved Western
Gable elevation of the dwelling which
included a large area of glazing however
the glazing served a void area so views
directly out of the glazing would have
been restricted as now proposed the area
of glazing in the western Gable has been
significantly reduced it now comprises a
small window at first floor level and a
further window at the top of the Gable
end internally the void has been removed
at first floor and the window will serve
a dressing room this has been set out
within the officer's report
here we have a floor plan comparison to
highlight the internal changes the
window serves the dressing room
associated with the master bedroom the
window would look towards the rear
Garden associated with the chinnaries
this is a photograph of the constructed
Western facade of the dwelling
and this is a photograph of the Eastern
elevation of the neighboring dwelling of
the chinnaries this window serves the
bedroom
with regard to Landscaping the most
significant change which is proposed is
the revised Landscaping plan is the
introduction of awards for Eastern
southern and western boundaries of the
site native hedging was approved under
the previous application and whilst this
is still proposed it would be located
within the site behind the wall which
has been erected
as we can see from the following site
photographs the wall is constructed at
Brick with stone Wing walls to the front
Eastern elevation the building surprise
Hardwick are predominantly constructed
in Horton Stone and red brick
this is a view of the wall and a view of
the southern view from the top of church
end
[Music]
whilst Hedges are the predominant
boundary treatment where visible from
the public realm within the settlement
there are also other examples of hard
boundary treatments the most notable
being Park's house which is cited to the
immediate east of the application site
and is within the prize Hardware
Conservation Area Park's house has a
brick and stone wall located at
vehicular entrance point which is
visible When approaching the village in
the southern lead direction from the
north and this is directly opposite the
application site
I set out within the officers report the
variation of conditions 2 3 4 and 5
would not result in a material or
additional harm to the immunity of
neighboring properties would not
adversely impact the overall visual
immunity of the development and continue
to preserve the setting of The Prize
Hardware Conservation Area it's
therefore offices recommendation for the
application to be granted subject to the
following conditions found within the
report thank you
Monica thank you very much indeed let us
call our first Speaker of this item who
is Mr Stuart Hyde from prior's Hardware
Parish meeting
good evening Mr Hyde thank you very much
for your patience it's been a long
evening for all this
[Laughter]
I think you've got a good idea of how
this is going to work now so you'll have
three minutes It'll be 30 second morning
whenever you're ready oh that's fine I'm
ready uh so I have a short statement to
make sure Hyde uh chair of prize
Hardwick Parish meeting uh thank you for
allowing me to speak this evening uh
some others will be speaking they will
be presenting uh some pictures to
support their statements but not wishing
to see a thunder mine will be narrative
only uh I will be speaking specifically
about overlooking and Boundary issues
that arise from the variation plan being
considered here now
uh before I talk about those firstly
some quick background context for the
village so price Hardwick is a small
idyllic Village beautiful even set in
the month so open Countryside uh near to
the town of uh
she'd be a bit nervous um it was the
first time
it has within its heart Conservation
Area and listed ancient Monument site
the plotting question sits on the edge
of the conservation area and has
approved provision for a dwelling this
application it was supported by The
Village at the parish meeting held in
August 2020.
resulting house is impressive
but it does contain a number of
differences from the approved plan of
which there are real concerns over to
the overlooking and banding issues
the first issue is as mentioned by the
uh the planning officer is the window so
in the dressing room in the western
Gable this was built of clear glass and
directly overlooks immediate neighboring
property the children the planning
officer is recommending that the windows
is obscure based I fully support this
even also if the replacement glazing
installation is a permanent glazed
nature and not a temporary one such as
removal fill
second issue is the boundary wall that
is adjacent to the road church end the
original approved application included a
landscaping plan of natural native
planning along the road boundary that is
consistent with treatments throughout
the village and the conservation area
the village in its supported this the
boat finished though and included in the
variation is a high brick wall along the
majority of the road boundaries the
remains of being the house on the entry
gates for the driveway although planning
officer notes that there is a similar
brick wall I've sent for the picture on
the adjacent property across the road it
is materially smaller perhaps tiny even
in comparison and that I'm aware of
there is no such precedent elsewhere in
the village but this scale all this
proximity to the road oh sorry I was
gonna say 30 seconds okay it is and
would be an imposing construction if
approved and as such this does not
supported it would materially change the
character and look at the village and
Conservation Area to which the plot
abounds and the words of the planning
officer it is regrettable
thank you oh it feels throughout the
Bible appreciate your time
marvelous thank you very much sorry for
cutting across I thought I got you at a
pause but yeah you can't hit it
I remember I was I was babbling members
do we have any questions for our
no in that case Mr Hyde thank you very
much for your time and patience and I'm
sorry it's too hot
[Music]
we will we will call our next speaker
who of the evening who is Mr Paul
hobbday
okay Mr holiday I think again you've got
the drill haven't you you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're already uncomfortable the
floor is yours excellent thank you Mr
chairman I'm Paul hobbday I live at
chinnaries I'm the nearest neighbor to
the planning variation application
I've objected to the application
2201-203 vary for the following planning
reasons the requested substitution of
drawings causes overlooking and loss of
privacy to the entire rear Garden of the
neighboring house chinnaries from the
window in the western Gable of a newly
built house
this window above my garden can be seen
in one of the photographs most people
showed the other ones I sent in
that's it thank you
the planning approval
um in 2020 which was approved specifies
drawings which avoid overlooking loss of
privacy to all the rear Garden
auxiliaries
this is achieved because the extensive
legalized Western
cable should have continuous internal
wall screening or the glazing at first
or level perhaps you can see the other
contrasting him please thank you very
not a great scale but it's there
um
there should be no first law to stand on
between the internal wall and the
glazing it's labeled as a void these
features can be seen on the approved
plans which are visible to you now
the 2020 approved planning application
confirmed multiple times the desire to
avoid overlooking and loss of privacy
for example the design and access
statement states it is carefully
designed not to overlook The Neighbors
it also States occupants of new and
neighboring buildings would be protected
from loss of privacy
pre-application planning advice from
Louise Casey of Stratford District
Council expressed clear concerns about
the position and orientation of the
house before the 2020 application
I was relief to see the architect of the
2020 plans had done his best to ensure
privacy
because of these assurances I supported
the 2020 planning application and I'm
disappointed to find significant changes
have occurred this overlooking window
frame first appeared in November 2021.
in discussion at the time I was told
Frosty glass would be fitted a few days
later clear glass was fitted
in October 22 11 months later a plastic
frosted film was applied just prior to
this meeting
the current variation application does
not specify obscure glazing if approved
this planning application would allow
the applicant to revert to clear glazing
30 seconds
could I ask please that the planning
department considers applying a planning
condition that any first floor windows
in the western Gable must permanently be
obscure glazed your assistance is much
appreciated from Paul University
thank you thank you very much indeed
just bear with me for one receive any
questions anyone got any questions Mr
hobday don't think so in that case Mr
Lee thank you very much for your time
many thanks and of course your patience
okay uh our final speaker of the evening
is Mr Mr counselor Rock sorry
been devoted tripping over my own
thunder tonight
at the council Northern Rock
cancer Rock um you'll have five minutes
you've got I'll give you sorry you've
got five minutes I'll give you 30
seconds so the officers got martial arts
ready already so thank you very much
same with you okay uh during the build
of this house diversions from the
approved class were made
if those changes had been applied for it
in advance all but two would have been
approved without controversy
the added window overlooking the private
spaces of the enabling property can be
readily dealt with by the use of the
council standard condition for
obscuration as the officers are
recommending and which are support we've
got slide one there
the second concern is the boundary
treatment
as acknowledged in the original
application prize Hardwick is an
exceptionally picturesque of almost a
picture postcard Village
I would refer to page 71 the last
paragraph and the last two paragraphs of
page 72 of the report
I note that the officer considers the
scheme to be regrettable by replacing
the Hedge with walls
this is a straightforward case whether
we want to allow these retrospective
changes which forms the boundary of the
conservation area perhaps slide two
please
the designer access statement of the
approved application included these
pictures showing the original Hedges
compared with other features in the
conservation area making the case for
development in this setting
the approved design Illustrated a
carefully thought out hedge with Native
species planting following the line of
the road
could have slide three please
what has been built however are three
sections of high walls part brick part
Stone fronting onto the highway with a
protruding corner
this construction does not Accord with
rspd4 which requires front walls and
fences adjacents to roads to be limited
to 1.2 meters even if they were not
forming the boundary to a Conservation
Area
it also does not comply with SPD part n
for landscaping and trees I'm gonna have
slide four please
the top plan is the is the one that was
approved including the Hedge and the
lower one the scheme before you now
the plot is prominent to key entrance to
the Village
the long wall that has been built to the
south terminates in the sharp corner
protruding further into the Verge than
the 45 degree chamfered off hedge line
than that that originally proposed in
the top picture
Slide Five please
there was a tree and Route protection
plan in the original application which
appears to have been breached so there
is some question that the growth which
partially protects the view of the brick
wall from the village will not be so
softened in the future
put up slide six please
this is a fine house and commands the
entrance to the Village from sandton
partly reflecting the design of Park's
house opposite built I Believe by the
same family
but these 51 meters of walls in their
setting is quite unlike on any other
feature in the conservation area where
all the other boundaries are hedges were
in a few cases low walls mostly Stone
the only wall that approaches it in
character is the one at parks house
opposite but this is a shorter wall
eight meters long fronted by planting
set well back and parallel to the road
the committee needs to consider if this
warning is appropriate to the
conservation area vernacular regardless
of whether it is retrospective or have
been submitted in advance
the sole consideration should be it's
accordance with the guidance for
conservation areas spds and the core
strategy could you flip back to side
three please
consistency is an issue
in June this year for an application in
the prize mastering Conservation Area
the applicants were advised against a
wall of similar height to this one and
that hedge would be more acceptable
subsequently that high was withdrawn
from the application and a low War
substituted and then approved the key
difference seems to be they asked first
elsewhere plan inspectors have taken the
view that unduly dominant boundary
features constitute harm where they are
incongruous with and detract from the
qualities of the conservation areas
are therefore suggest that the warmer
the war harms the character and
appearance of the conservation area is
contrary to the mppa and our policies
cs8 cs9 and cs12 also SPD Part D and
part n
also rather than make the positive
contribution as desired by paragraph one
three one of the framework the
development harms the local character
thank you very much
thank you very much I was going to give
you a 30 second warning but I put my
faith in you that you will come into an
end and you did indeed that was a relief
I must say yeah not because you came to
the end but anyway
um members do you have any questions for
our Ward member Council Dixon please uh
Castle Rock local knowledge
um Park House opposite obviously uh that
wall has some vegetation uh as it were
helping to hide it
could a similar situation be provided at
this one or is that Highway languages
can't be as it were in people
in fact I anticipated your question
because I went and bought the land
registry plan
and the wall forms the boundary of the
of the site according to the land
registry I believe I've supplied the
officer if you want you to see it the
picture of the wall I think the officers
got this one of my earlier slides if
it's the middle one on the right in one
of those if you wanted to see it because
that does have some planting it as you
quite rightly point out
uh
that one yep that's nicely hidden but
Council Parry please
thank you councilor Rock
um it's unfortunate that the applicant
isn't here this evening otherwise I
would have liked to have asked them the
question but if I may ask you
um presumably you've had some
conversations with the applicant and if
so did you did you ask them why they
opted to go for the war rather than the
plan vegetation hedging which is
on my knowledge of this lovely Village
um more more typical I've not had any
interaction with the applicant they've
not approached me and obviously they
have not approached them
and we have any other
questions or points of clarification
that's sorry questions for our war
member crikey no in that case councilor
rock thank you very much for your time
and contribution this evening
um plus clarification do we have any of
those
counselor
sorry just to help my understanding
while we're flicking around lots of
photos
um there was one photograph where the
wall clearly changes color of brink
um
where it changes is that where the Hedge
would have started or would it have gone
all the way up to the gay blend of the
house
it would demarcate the whole of the I
think that's kind of how I read the
plans yeah but yeah it just looks off
any other application councilor Harvey
please
the the window that the offending window
that overlooks
is it within our power this evening to
require that to be removed rather than
just
um
glazed
that's one question
if it's on the plans it's on the plans
okay fine
um
secondly is it open to us to require the
wall to be demolished
again it's it's it's within the plant
and it's also included within the
description of development so no you
can't make a split decision saying that
you approve certain elements but you you
in effect you can be refusing that part
of that variations or we don't yes
on if I if I may on that um point and I
think uh Council Dixon was going along
the same lines
um would it be uh appropriate or
suitable for us to put a condition on to
reinstate the Hedge in front of that
wall
I I know that the reason I asked for it
as a separate conditions on the
Landscaping because I know that the um
condition two is in accordance with
Landscaping scheme and replacement
planting which I assume means the old
one we can't adjust that because it's
part of a previous application oh the
apart the other approved adding a
condition in to ensure that a hedge is
in front of that will go a long way to
making me more comfortable
I understand that the um the red line
surrounding the site
but directly abuts the wall so in effect
you wouldn't be able to put a condition
on requiring them to do works that are
outside of their land wouldn't it be it
wouldn't be the tests
particularly we we don't know whether
they own it and we don't know whether
it's cancer
my understanding of playing law is that
I could in theory put an application on
Council cases land and he frequently
does
what you're saying what you're saying is
if if that was granted I wouldn't be
able to do it unless he gave him
permission so we could put the condition
on but it would have to get permission
to the land is that correct or is that
am I completely out of the
no you're it's two separate things when
you're applying a condition it has there
has to be a reasonable Prospect of
um the condition being able to be
implemented we don't have any evidence
that that land is within their ownership
within a blue line or the red line of
the plan we can't give that guarantee
then it can be so it wouldn't it
wouldn't meet the tests got you you very
much councilor Parry
um I'm just thinking if if the committee
were minded to Grant on the Obscure
glazing can we
um insist that that is a com it's it's
glass
obscurity it's not film that's put on
the back
because in my view if it's if it's going
if it's got to be obscure glazing it's
got to be
oops it's got to be a permanent
situation not a not a obscure piece of
film that could be removed
I believe we can Council of Harry yeah
the the standard conditions it tends to
reflect
the similar approaches in Community
Development but if counselors are
worried about the permanency of it
obviously it is the condition is for the
lifetime of the development and also we
could include that it's it's not
openable if that is something that would
help
for what it's worth and I don't want to
strengthen debate yet but it's not
uncommon to have a film there and as as
we've heard from Emily the the condition
is in perfect erity so if that were to
be peeled off or taken away it has to go
back on again on an own bridge and we
would ensure that well I say we it would
be an enforcement case um I have no
doubt it was going to take into
enforcement properly
um but I do understand your point
councilor Mills someone else
um could you put the photograph up of
the offending window can you put it up
for me please
[Music]
that is it is it is it is it a bedroom
or is it a bathroom
dressing room
fine huh no I've got two yeah
right so okay so yeah okay
Council cases thank you signals as well
have you got one yeah no it was on the
point of it being a non-opening glazed
window which has already been covered
thank you okay in that case if there are
no councilor Harvey let's move into
debate councilor Harvey would you like
to kick off yes
before but I visited the site I drove
around the village
um and it struck me that it's accurate
to say that the village is built of both
Halton stone and brick that is true but
it is very predominantly Horton Stone
um rather than brick I didn't I may have
missed them but I didn't see any other
brick walls uh boundary walls I saw
houses where there were a mixture of
brick and Horton Stone
um so that tells me that this my
interpretation of what I saw was this is
a very prominent brick wall
on the Eastern approach to to the
village and it is very very noticeable
that's one thing the second thing is I
looked up um Google Earth looked the
site up and you can only see it from the
road Junction but what that photograph
or that what that picture shows you is
the the site before the work began and
it shows the Hedge and I have to say the
contrast between what was there and what
is there now is it was very Stark and
I'm very sympathetic to councilman
Rock's point of view that what is there
now is it is red brick there is red
brick in in in the village but to my
eyes and my appreciation it is
disproportionately intrusive and harmful
in the context of the village as a whole
can I just check whether you are you you
are proposing refusal for that reason
I have a difficulty because I S uh on
the grounds of the window is obscured I
can understand the reasonableness of the
other other variations but so I'm I'm
stuck I'm I I would much prefer that
what was approved as far as the boundary
I.E the retention of the Hedge was was
reinstated and the wall was pulled down
but I I recognize I've either got a vote
for one or the or the whole basket
so I'm going to assume for what you've
just said that you're not proposing it
at this stage not at this stage in that
case I'm going to
for the same reasons you've put
um I've got no problem with the Obscure
glaze window I don't like it it's I
think that's ugly but that's my personal
subjective view
um the wall I I can't I can't see away
getting around it um whilst I accepted
that uh within the village there are
examples of red brick and hortonstone
combined and indeed we've seen a picture
of that we've also seen a picture of
that with lots of flowers and planting
what have you in front of it makes it
very pretty I thought that was lovely at
that point I was thinking yeah this we
could we could work our way around this
we have heard that that boundary the red
line boundary sits right on the edge of
that wall which means anything that's
planted on the other side we have been
told
shouldn't be there it's not their land
shouldn't be doing it so it can't be
hidden and on the basis is that it can't
be hidden I think it caused material
harm to the uh Street Scene to the
Village to that area I'm proposing that
we refuse on that basis councilor Parry
please
you jumped ahead of me councilor
Richards
um I actually drive through plaz
Hardwick two or three times a week it's
on route to see my grandchildren
um
and it is one of the most picturesque
Villages
um just south of southam a lot of Hawk
and stone and I cannot possibly
um
I just can't support this application
because of the hard Landscaping of that
wall I could have lived with the with
the window
um but it is it is totally out of
character of The Village which is very
quaint very it's the Cotswold um it's
not Cotswold it's called non-stone
um
which is very familiar to this part of
Warwickshire and also South
northamptonshire
um and therefore I'm happy to Second
your
um proposal to refuse
planning application thank you very much
we have some Mills next please
I did take a look at the application and
went through the flood there yeah that
that wall I mean it just uh stands out
like a sort of thumb and I have to agree
with uh
councilor uh clever Harvey and Perry and
yourself Mr chairman
um yeah I haven't really have to be
accused I think
cancel text next please
essentially if I think the original
application that indicated a war like
that we wouldn't have guaranteed
permission in the first place
um but I think by refusing this
variation now which is where I would be
voting uh is a situation whereby the
applicant can either take down the wall
and reset a hedge alternatively see if
there is any way they can themselves
acquire a strip of land in front of that
wall whereby they can actually hide that
with some vegetation
okay
um just mind for the fact that that is
not an indication that we might run
something in the future clearly we will
take whatever is presented to us at
first but I understand your sentiment
um short of asking people to repeat the
same thing over and over again we have a
proposal to refuse for good for good
reasons
I should for reasons I should say I
would say they're good they were mine
um and it's been seconded um
uh let's have a vote on that and then
obviously we can move on from there so
yes um I'm just being reminded that we
should uh that wording will be delegated
to the officers for that reason for
refusal
um it's got to have a show of hands for
those in favor of
refusing
[Music]
I could I please have a show of hands
for those in favor of refusing uh
application
2201203 very uh that appears to be
unanimous so committee therefore has
resolved to refuse application
2201203 very uh land adjacent to the
chinaries in price Hardwick for the
reasons given
um we do have no urgent business you'll
be pleased to know so members thank you
very much for your time and contribution
officers thank you very much for yours
as well and of course the public too and
of course ask a new sound man thank you
very much uh we'll see in a couple of
weeks